hey oh there it is all right can you
hear now can you hear now are we good
are we good we're getting uh sound waves
here so uh you
know this is going great yeah yeah yeah
no sound no sound still no
sound we go fix okay well John you you
were there with me and John
like the like
fine
fine oh no we're
lagging this doesn't make any sense it
does make sense we should have done it
in the main house all right just move
this computer back no John there's no
time all right there's no time capacity
it's okay this is this is no this is how
it goes don't stress
out I need to just be able to see the
chat I will talk with people okay while
you do stuff alrighty guys well listen
um I just wanted to say that it's not
John's
fault okay did I pay the internet bill I
paid it six months in advance so I
didn't have to think about about it yeah
I did that right before the end of the
year as a tax right off so that I didn't
have to think about that [__] because I
constantly missed the internet
F it's okay you're gonna poor John oh
look oh let's re let's resurrect the
poor Jon sentiment again yes boohoo
that's how Jon gets through
Lifey all right oh John all right I'm
just GNA start talking and see what
happens all right
are we lagging does that mean we're
lagging uh what I mean yeah we're
totally lagging are we it currently says
excellent but it keeps
fluctuating this feels like a YouTube
problem but I can't I cannot uh
rightfully tell I don't know why you two
would be lagging I don't know why we
lost 50 viewers John chat Sorry God John
there you go good now I can just look at
the chat I don't really want to talk to
anyone okay
well for the moment the stream is
healthy so it's not it's totally not
yeah no
data there's no data well it it it keeps
going I think those are the lags is when
it says no data it means yeah if it's uh
the Youtube fa sh in the main house I
don't know if well I mean the down and
upload speeds are are consistent with
normal so it shouldn't be this bad but
oh Cody Le it's okay go watch Cody Lee
he's cool I think I don't know
personally but you know he makes content
people like
so I think maybe what we should do is um
okay what's it at right
now I gotta have to cut all this out
dude this is it's going on okay all
right I'm gonna get sincere here for a
second it's kind of going off a little
bit too much it's happening a little too
often and I feel like we need to kind of
do something about this in a serious
manner okay so should I call the
internet company and see
what's I personally wouldn't have 2024
be any other way because this is just
going to be a great memory and a great
story to tell people down the road you
know what I mean all right if we're not
really lagging then I guess we're just
gonna do
it all right I think we're just going to
do it all right all right all right
people are saying it's fine so we should
just keep going it's fine all right I'll
go back to making it abusing John in
just a a second but I had to get sincere
for a second I'm sorry kills the
chemistry and I feel like that actually
ruins the uh impression that people have
of our Dynamic sure so I I'm sorry it's
okay sorry I didn't mean to I didn't
mean to do that I'll get through it
somehow yeah I'll figure it out I know I
paid in advance that way that we don't
deal with this [__] and it's getting
worse than before you paid in advance so
that they can check out and be like ah
whatever so here's what we're going to
do all right a few minutes
see no I don't want to do that can't we
just go to where it's actually at on the
540 540 you're the guy you're the guy
for for those you know how to cut to the
chase so alrighty uh I think we should
just do the stream and see how it goes
and if it's really starting to lag uh
you guys just need to let me know and is
the mic level adjustments really bad
right now
John uh should they be they're they're
they are normal they're currently what
we always
use I don't know all righty well we're
going to do it and no matter how awkward
it gets we're going to do it no no no
they're saying it's too low oh yeah kind
us up a bit more how's that you just let
us
know
I gotta just it's really bugging me now
now I got to see what it's at now now
I'm at a point where I just got to see
what how it's playing for you guys
because I'm thinking about the playback
and I'd rather just wait a little bit
longer and start again like for a third
time lose more viewers as long as if we
can just have an actual goodlook stream
then then because right now it it
because it keeps going from it's fine to
it's not fine and it's it's fluctuating
way too much
much alrighty okay we have lost way too
many viewers John we need to get this
going all right
alrighty okay here we go we're g to
start this off one last time we're going
to kick this off one more time and we're
gonna go uh we're going to do a quick
recap if you was thank you to all for
helping us have a fantastic 2023 year
year uh it literally was our best year
we've ever had and not just in terms of
whatever you measure success by but also
in terms of um like how we feel about
the what we
produce as well you know like the
combination of both it's like a win
thing last time uh people like holiday
Tom James Christian harof uh Olivia my
wife who's done a couple videos of me
this year so I really do think and she
helps out so much behind the scenes as
well and I think that uh it was like the
best year ever for a variety of reasons
for real rejects I'm excited to go
forward with
2024 and and then and with that in mind
uh we have some super chats that I know
we do got to catch up on all suck and I
think especially this one's going to
suck so thank you guys so much for um
the thank you guys so much for everyone
who has been contributing and also John
was saying his most anticipated movie of
the year is the newest Silent Hill film
my most anticipated movie is Deadpool 3
for a variety of reasons I imagine that
we are go John we just have to ignore I
imagine that as we are going to be going
through this stream some of our opinions
might repeat itself a tad bit so I just
want to see what you guys are saying I
do feel bad about what happened last
Stream So John I would like to catch up
on what we missed on the last Super
chats if you don't mind oh sure yeah
yeah yeah I'm sorry we will talk about
TV shows we missed quite a few people
last time because we had to cut the
stream short but I'm going to make sure
everything here is going to be going
according to plan even if it's buffering
like
crazy it's all good all right we are
here uh we did we miss super chats last
year I feel like we read all of these
but uh we didn't read any super chats
last time John oh oh oh you mean from
the from today sorry the last the last
the last streaman no no no a bu it's all
the same to me yes we're here we got him
uh see Deadpool 3 is definitely the one
uh that I'm most looking forward to did
you pull it up Deadpool 3 the the super
chats yes but the I just want to make
sure that you're prepared because when
we magnify them it's going to demolish
the chat how so it's going to 500% Zoom
the chat well then we bring the chat
back and we readjust it all right here
we
go oh my God what has happened to the
YouTube stream it's everything that
always happens you didn't bother to to
First change it on the OBS
John okay you can go back I mean that
probably would have been the smart thing
to First eliminate it from the OBS so
that way we can hearing on screen John
sure well I mean this GNA
stay why would it stay John uh because
you
know it doesn't make any sense where
you're getting at it's okay there we go
o I don't like the way it looks well
you're going to love it in a hot second
here I don't like it there we go looks
great that looks perfect we got a dollar
sign at the top we got to show the
monetary value that we freak to this
super track yeah totally man it's great
no joh why I got this under control man
don't please there is no need to panic
at this time watch guys at this time oh
don't trust me there's going to be
plenty of reasons to panic I'm lost and
he is
gone we do need to hit up OB all right
John yeah that's me why don't you just
talk a little bit she seems so this year
and I just can't keep it all inside I
don't treat John like we're an old mared
couple I don't
never we've never been married I treat
John the way John should be treated it's
what I invite upon myself truly truly
and honestly uh you probably what you
want to do is uh
also is also I didn't mean to upset you
comp people think I'm the abusive one
but people have no idea what John's like
behind the scenes yeah I am I'm like
leam Michelle can't read I was missing
that was the step I was missing John
that's where you come in handy there you
go John you did it man you did it dude
hey that's not too bad should be
fine hey John before I slap you around
can you tell people that I'm actually
kind of nice to you when the camera's
not rolling Craig hardly ever slaps me
anymore Ash free John that's the best
comment ashree John I I will blink thri
if I am under
duress John normally you surrender to
the craziness that's happening and you
just seem so tight right now in the
shoulders what's going on I need a
massage I haven't had one in all of 2024
is that really what's happening right
now that I'm tighten the shoulders
because I yeah well you
know my my brain is brain is woring
right now what are you worried about the
gears are turning and I'm trying to
ignore the gears in favor of just
focusing on my most anticipated okay
fine okay John please I could yeah here
we this is my plan all along oh yeah
you're so sweaty am I yeah you're moist
why do you have such moist shoulders oh
maybe that's my spray conditioner
everywhere that's how I do you know
that's how I show that I love you don't
you know that when you draw attention to
someone behaving a little bit tense that
that makes them it Rel it makes them
loosen up you know
yeah yeah like work out a knot this is a
really nice like one area massage though
this is like I'm like Myer know what I'm
doing I can feel the knots oh yeah you
see this is great because I like to give
hard massages and Olivia hates the way I
massager oh dude so now instead of
massaging my wife I can massage John
this works out for the both of us this
works out so well and like you know my
muscles like I'm I'm trying to stretch
we will read the every day I promise
because my muscles tend to be so tight
when I was getting my physical therapy
from my back and my hamstrings like they
they extended my leg and they were like
have you ever seen a hamstring this
tight you know you know what I love
about this guys is that we have barely
talked my Jo thank you for kicking off
our first Super Chat of the Year yes
buddy the movie I am most excited for is
Beetle juu 2 Beetle Juice 2 Beetle Juice
2 oh no you know uh I'm actually excited
for this mov movie John do you know why
I'm excited for this movie because Tim
Burton admitted that his time at Disney
has been detrimental yes exactly he
mitted his time has been detrimental he
has talked about how this felt like he
is he himself is returning to form with
this I love the addition of Jen Ortega
who has you know blossomed into super
stardom with the movie Wednesday which
Tim Burton cast her in uh the show
Wednesday which Tim Burton Caster in and
now she's a superstar and so to see
what's happening here the return of
Michael Keon the whole shebang I just I
really feel like this is coming from a
good place and and Tim buron has
postponed doing the sequel for so long
and I think he really felt like there
was it was the right to being um uh you
know find finding their love for Tim
buron once again you know yeah no I mean
I I am apprehensive for obvious reasons
but I am curious and excited and I do
hope that this marks a return to form
for a filmmaker I used to love and be so
excited by and has recently you know
taken an uninspiring
turn so uh so yeah like as much as a
sequel like this at a moment in time
like this is a bit of a dubious Prospect
in some ways I feel like there is a
solid a good chance that this could
actually be something special if not you
know it's got to live up to the first
movie blah blah but like I don't know I
think it could be pretty cool you know I
tried um mage dodging um terara on on
screen and uh she got really upset and
said it was very inappropriate well what
movie were you watching is the right
question to ask 12 years of slave yes
well I mean I would take a massage
during that it's because of all my white
guilt um but you know so I don't know
what her problem was and then my wife
came in and she was Ying she's like you
shouldn't be touching uh other women
like that and I said shut up and then
she
filed for divorce and I said I'm sorry
I'm not signing this and I said I can't
sign this right now I just can't afford
a divor getting divorced I'll pay for
the internet and our second Super Chat
of the Year driving ahead in this stream
super excited for your reaction to the
Percy Jackson TV show it's really good
uh yeah I've heard amazing things about
it what T and I want to do is watch uh
the second movie because I've heard
nothing but great things about it and
especially after that first movie all
those things I've seen in all expecting
it and I just know that it's going to be
met with nothing but why did you just
cover this show why' you do this movie
but that's why we have to do it and and
uh terara has been really sick um if you
follow her on social media she's been
obnoxiously sick arguably I should be
paying her a visit but instead I'm just
like why aren't you better can you just
hurry up we got to film this Percy
Jackson show and I feel like I they're
like you're not a good boss Greg you're
not to check up on me you only care
about getting me or you keep threatening
to fire me if I don't get better and I'm
like well that's America for you Tera
that's yeah that's America for you I I
have a I mean I want to hear more about
your adventures with Percy Jackson but I
feel like we should acknowledge this one
thing from the chat just what that scram
7 is rumored to maybe be being ret
tooled as just a reboot with no
continuation is that true verify it in
the chat I think you just totally got
like catfished here a damn Sky the mag
as just some like random thing that
someone saying in the chat I don't know
man how to get someone's it could be a
real rumor be a real rumor it is rumor
is indeed a real rumor have made it a
real
rumor missed oh all right drive on the
Super Chat our third Super Chat of the
year goes to Conor Lawrence who says o
mate you guys are great thank you oi
mate thank you so much love you wherever
you're from if you're out in Australia
or New
Zealand uh yeah I think Stu will live in
Scream s I feel like they got to just go
all out on Scream 7 just going to get
the out of the way all out they got to
bring back Nev Campbell Courtney Cox
Dewey Jamie Kennedy uhuh uh uh Sarah
Michelle Geller sure throw and Freddy
Prince Jr in there yeah yeah Jennifer
Love hwit Ryan philippy do the whole
shebang get Devon Sawa in there West
Craven deep fak him yes you got to do
the whole thing and Bam I guarantee you
everyone's going to forgive all the
things that happened and it's a
crossover with Five Nights at Freddy's
oh number four here hey number four real
31k real happy belated New Year everyone
looking forward to all the content this
year thank you so much looking forward
all the content this year too well you
said looking forward to all the content
this year so I'm going to use this as an
opportunity based off of a couple of
things I saw in the chat here to bring
it back to the topic at hand one thing
I'm very much looking forward to finally
getting this year I feel like undou ably
probably relatively soon is we're
finally going to get the
announcement year after month I I I
don't know what the deal is you know
what would be cool if they film it and
we never find out I miss a time where
would be possible you know there's a
time where we we were able to get away
with something like that but how how
excellent would it be if we if they
happen to just shoot it and then the
first thing we get is like a teaser
trailer yeah and they still don't show
us the faces then everyone has to come
to movie to see the faces dude I think
variety is full of [__] I gotta say
variety's stock has has lowered in terms
of like my the the their like drama
clickbait [__] is is is a ridiculous a
bit like it's a bit much I'm not here
to I'm going to slightly defend the Dave
Chappelle right oh I watched it right
when it came out yes and then the first
first thing I see is like it's from
variety is like it's nothing but a
barrage of trans fobe jokes and then and
then there's also like are there some
trans jokes in there there's a few is
there some um is and I'm not here to say
like whether or not you should or
shouldn't be offended I'm just saying
like the way they pitch it is it's just
this like onslaught of jokes I'm like
it's not it's just him yelling TR people
for an hour and a half and then the
other one is um they took a a line that
he says
and they made it seem like the way when
you put it in a quote tweet when in
you're when you're trying to get people
to click your article when he says I
like I love to punch
down the way they present it makes it
seem like he's just telling people a
fact about himself of like but I'm like
no it's it's clear in this special that
that is a satirical comment he is making
right there it's a joke yeah and then
you but when you read it it's just like
Dave Chappelle's admitting like like
that's not what's happening there he's
he's confronting and challenging the
idea I'm not saying whether or not you
should or shouldn't be offended by [__]
he says that's not what I'm saying I am
saying that like I was very much in that
moment going the way you're presenting
this is not at all what actually happens
in this and it's sad because variety and
Hol you know variety and Hollywood
Reporter were like the two Mega uh you
know trades and now to see variety at
least their reputation plummet so hard
has been fascinating and and kind of a
bummer you know definitely John remember
the olden days I think we got a read
from Cairo here who was our fifth Super
Chat of the Year number five I'm keeping
track I'm not going to write it down I'm
just going to remember okay Cairo what
is Cairo saying John dude Cairo is
saying thoughts is asking thoughts on
Henry caval and Amazon reaching an
agreement with Games Workshop for a
Warhammer if they have reached an
agreement that seems about ideal because
as we all know know Henry caval
dedicated gamer loves Warhammer 40,000
and uh I think that if you could get out
of project that people want to make that
he's excited about that maybe has the
chance to just do what it wants to do
unencumbered just is for Henry caval
because like he has had a weird rough go
of it in terms of the public eye and the
roles he's been able to inhabit well
definitely I feel like especially for
Henry caval uh when it came to The
Witcher he he was very much outspoken
about how if it ain't
broke don't fix it that's the
quote that's that's the saying if you
ain't broke don't get money if it is not
broke all about the books and then when
it started to deviate to my
understanding as someone who has not
played the games or read the books to my
understanding it deviates very much so
from it or it really does its own thing
and he wanted out and um I think with
him on this it sounds like he's also a
producer who's going to be involved with
the actual um creativity of this that it
if if there's one thing that I feel like
we're all going to be getting you're G
to get something faithful yeah you know
you're gonna get something that he's at
least able to make sure that isn't
retooled and or watered down because I
he's had both versions of that
experience he's had you know the dream
role you know completely reworked by
Major Studio like after the fact and
before the fact something like Witcher
so I hope that this is his opportunity
to get like a dream project that isn't
marred by something but guys in the chat
um in the chat are are you guys excited
for to see what Chris Hemsworth brings
are you excited to see if Chris
Hemsworth will deliver I am morbidly
curious I don't think we're going to
react to it honestly Liam Hemsworth what
did I say you said Chris and I was like
are we going to furiosa right now cuz I
am anticipating furiosa but uh but yeah
Liam everyone's favorite Hemsworth Liam
Hemsworth definitely Jeff Carrol Jeff
Carrol who is I'm to make things
complicated is going to be our sixth
seventh and eighth Super Chat of that's
what we like to see that's how you do it
all right Jeff Carrol okay let's read
all three of these and then we're going
to see what we have it sounds like
you've given us some things to riff off
of here which I really appreciate let's
do it says happy New Year guys got my
wife a space baby shirt for exus and she
loves it I'm glad she does it's one of
our favorites thank you so much for
getting that from reation shop.com
really looking forward to dunu Dun
double P3 inside out two and curious to
see what comes out of the animated Lord
of the Rings film oo I don't know much
about that okay let's just read the rest
of these really quick also can't wait
for Tera to get better as he gets to the
Percy Jackson show as my favorite book
series of all time so grateful the show
is bringing it to life so beautifully
it's so faithful to the books and going
it diverges it's purposeful and still
honors the source material oh that's
great to hear really great for my
favorite channel is gonna cover my
favorite book all love oh we're gonna
cover the book we're gonna read we're
gonna read the book on camera to
ourselves silently yes and then we will
give you we're going to give you the
most pure book reaction it's going to be
like a really protracted ASMR where you
hear the page turn once in a while
breathe so much time you're going to see
me going back cuz I'm going to like my
knowing me I'm going to read for a while
and be like oh my God I I don't even
know what I just read you need to like
go back and start like three pages ago
because I've just like let my brain
Trail off that's how a lot of my reading
happens so um Dune 2 I can't wait to see
this movie John because uh that's one
we're definitely going to watch in the
theaters no matter what no matter what
uh Dune 2 I feel so bad for
Den this guy I mean remember like he had
the all that with the first dude movie
yeah and that got released that with the
the year of HBO Max and them releasing
everything day and day
still did well in the theaters and then
the delays here but he wants us to lead
into the um the the rest of the um the
rest of the derse yeah I Don't Know Jack
about it I have friends who are so into
the derse and I'm like that sounds great
can't wait to watch it can't yeah I
can't wait to be given the cliffs notes
I'm I'm definitely not going to be
reading that anytime soon but sounds
cool man but I see the way they light up
and and and Denise uh rency for the
source mat material seems to shine on
screen according to what other people
say but regardless I mean that's the
cool bridge that I feel like theying you
know yeah yeah absolutely I mean like
it's again it's always anytime something
is deemed unfilmable or like way too
ambitious like is always it's a fun
Prospect to live under because someone's
going to do it and this was one of them
where that's all I knew about it is like
David Lyn tried and no and did not
succeed and and so yeah uh I I'm just ex
I I want to know what will be different
or what will be sort of expanded upon
with uh Dune 2 versus the first dune
movie um but yeah I'm I'm quite excited
and to see how that expands into you me
to take that there see how that expands
into these shows and I mean he said he
wants to do the third book movie also
and has said you know I'm going to take
a break before I do that but I want to
do a third movie too so uh yeah I mean
that's the thing now is like I know they
can do it and I know it's going to look
pretty it's going to you know change and
what they're going to add to it and all
that stuff you know and uh and yeah
welcome back to normal C it's a good
thing I showered at this one because I
had a
towel clean hey it was all meant to be
all this was meant to be I want this
backd job yeah you should have it it's a
good thing for you to have okay all
righty well and then of course inside
out too yes I Pixar is really a need of
a rebound and and I really think that a
sequel is honestly the way to go like
clearly their originals are not
something that audiences are flocking to
even when they're phenomenal like
they're not or because and it's Disney's
fault it it is it is what Disney has
done with their like putting the day
they decided to put soul on Disney Plus
was one of the most I eluded the
theatrical going experience immensely
for the Pixar brand and and I think a
way to get audiences back into Pixar is
deliver a great sequel that's that's
really just the way it is because I
think people's Nostalgia and the love
that they have for it will warrant them
will will compel them to go back to the
theaters I think yeah forward and they
need they need like a big hit like
Elemental did well but it it it it was
one of those movies are like it had legs
it grew it picked up steeve but it was
not a juggernaut the way how Pixar used
to be and it wasn't big out out the gate
it's twofold yeah because Pixar both has
been diluted by Disney's uh streaming
practices but I think they also they
need a redefining moment because like we
all associate Pixar with things that are
off of making like Transcendent movies
that you know punch above what your
average a movie is doing and I feel like
that is also a thing they need to get
back to because uh we need to get back
to the cinema I mean kind of like that's
the thing is is I think Soul comes quite
close I I think it it borders on
Transcendent and I haven't seen Luca I
haven't seen Elemental um but it seems
like Pixar you know you'll see like a
pretty good or like an average to good
Pixar movie definitely whereas like the
greatness is a little further and
farther between now yeah yeah yeah um
but yeah I'm I'm hoping that that uh uh
Inside Out 2 could fill that role
because inside out one you know I
thought was probably if not Soul
probably the last time they had one that
was like man this is something
special be what number nine I it is
number nine a th% you nailed it my
friend number nine uh JP thank you for
jumping into the J stream uh dun also I
have you guys to thank as my main
inspiration for starting my own channel
and podcast asked this year thank you
guys much love and I love that you gave
yourself an echo echo echo I would love
to check out your podcast and and give
you a like John would love to be a guest
on your podcast yes I will wh me out
John John is going is ready to go all
out on JP MN podcast today anybody's
podcast but but love squeezing JW in
other people's schedules you know sure
whatever you need from me I'll do
whatever's uh worth what you know if if
you tell me good job I'll do it every
week he is telling me about his new
podcast that he wants to work on he's in
to study and I'm just like dude you just
got to do it I had like level with him
last time like you just got to do it
even if it's like shitty the first time
this is our second live stream today you
need to get that out of your system you
just got to do it and just make some
mistakes and then even if it's crap like
what matters is you got to find your
flow with does look at that you got so
many pods getting popped off now thank
you JP we appreciate you very much let
go for number 10 our 10th Super Chat of
the Year skeptical Soloman what two
movies in 2024 are you excited for well
John said John said yes here's what JN
said I want to tell you what JN said
Return to silent return to silent it's
not a hard title remember return to
Silent Hill yes and uh what's your Nas
Fatu nasu Robert Edgar cuz you're a huge
fan of the Northman and the lighthouse
and I didn't see witch I didn't see the
witch but I love the Norman most
pretentious horror nerd you'll ever meet
right here I've been saving the
lighthouse because for what is there a
video to make out of it or no for the
possib we figure out how to do the nor
that's how we gauge all of we go Natalie
gold do it clearly our views always
match up with her yeah sure if it's not
a reactable movie hey man dude we got a
year of delays uh yeah we're going to do
anything and everything this year this
is a year where we're just like screw it
if it gets 5,000 views we're doing it
throw it up there it works nicely it
plays well into my wretched time
management skills but also that I'm like
you know this is you seen the witch we
saw the witch together I was being a
joker you're being vicious being
factious by insinuating I'd seen the two
films I hadn't seen but not seen the one
I had hey Laura I got to say I don't
think Natalie gold sucks wow it has
reached the point where I'm like has she
not seen any movies every the thing
people say to us there's a reason there
are multiple hosts but I'm like yeah
there's a reason we have a lot of hosts
I'm like I hav't seen it but I'm like
wow she really hasn't seen like any
movie yeah um maybe someday Bad Medicine
bad medicine's one a collab that I
really do want to figure out and work
Bad Medicine I got to tell you bad wow
you're acting like you've never seen Bad
Medicine sorry for a second I thought
medicine even supports us on patreon I
know I wow like that's a bad look John
I'm not saying I don't know who Bad
Medicine is John why Nas feratu uh Nas
feratu because I am a huge fan of the
original 1920s
movie The FW mow joint and
I AMC to certainly but I feel like
Robert Edgar's it's the perfect blend of
a uh Talent with a
property kills my soul a little bit to
call it a property but you get what I
mean and I feel like if anybody can
update this in a way that's like freaky
that maybe has a little bit more of that
direct horror punch that people who find
the witch boring are looking for but
that will also have all the flourishes
of what he does uh his you know it
crazy attention to detail and parlance
and and language and all that stuff uh
yeah just I I'm am very and you know I
mean as much as uh uh uh Bill Skarsgard
playing count orlock is you know it's
like a very sensical choice for the here
and now uh I still think he could bring
a lot to that in terms of presence and
they're saying like oh man you don't
even know he's there so uh yeah I'm just
I'm very amped for that you know Bill
can play a variety of villains though
like he's been fantastic in Batman and
Spider-Man and he who was that called
the devil where's Prada was it of the
devil the devil all the time devil all
the time yes the devil all the time
devil all the time devil all the
time appreciate that Brandy saw a really
negative Twitter th about me about that
so thank you Brandy um so yeah that um
so I I feel like it'd be great my two
most
anticipated I'm going to what else is
coming out this oh I got a whole list
for you if you need them but they're my
pics they're my PS no I don't want there
are a couple there's one I know we're
both looking forward to Garfield
definitely no come on
joker I'm looking forward to that
because of Lady Gaga pretty much solely
the Bob Marley movie no no come on your
favorite person is in
it Peter sarsgard you're not looking
forward to the Fall Guy oh yeah [__]
movies are going to be so long and like
it could be very long movies are so like
they're always over stay they welcome
but it could be good and that's exciting
to me it's really hard to top Deadpool 3
for me I'll tell you my most anticipated
show uh is going to have to be uh boy
season 4 like that undoubtedly is my
most anticipated show I I feel like they
got something really special at their
hands when when as
especially knowing
um how the boy comic ends and then
seeing some things that were teased in
the trailer I was like oh that they
might actually be because cuz boy season
without going into any spoilers being
insanely vague here boy season 3 does
some things where you're like okay then
there's no way the boy season the boy
comic book can have the end like
anywhere near remotely close to the
ending in the comic is possible they
figure that [__] out yeah um our oh wait
a minute oh we got to do a refresh do it
John all right let's do that refresh get
ready people it's going to change
everything for the better in
2024 we're going to get to Super Chat
number 11 are you excited box that's
what he's been riding off of for years
now I know I got a haircut at the end of
last year and no one noticed imagine if
John bald
I don't think it would look good I think
Jensen's a th% in season 4 with the boys
somebody's oh yeah he's got to be they
they'll I should have reserved my uh TV
show answer for later oh craving the
hunter yeah yeah leave a like while
you're out in the rainforest researching
spiders when my mom died haven't seen
the Civil War trailer yet not yet
oh I think we're just going to react
that I'm excited cuz I feel like that
could go either way chat can you tell me
I want to watch sound of freedom and
people are like you'll get [__] for it
and I'm like but but I want to watch it
I'm very curious about it I'm very I'm
very I'm very curious yeah I mean like
it would be a good thought experiment
and and the thing is I've heard people
who have seen it come out and be like I
thought it was a fine movie and then I
learned about all the context
surrounding the movie so like it is does
seem like a hazardous roack I'd be fine
with just watching it and it was okay I
mean I don't
know seems loaded certainly but I just
want to watch it just to see it for the
movie it is and then and then go all
right well here's my opinion on it yeah
but and I feel like I can easily do that
as long as I just avoid looking up the
true story before I watch it and then
just take in the movie itself cuz yeah
there's there's like a lot of baggage
like people are saying but I I I was
like it's been on my list and I'm like I
want to react to it I do um but you know
it'll be an experience and there you go
who cares man you'll get everyone in the
middle fine movie everyone
all political parties everyone's welcome
here everyone Wicked that's right I
don't love Ariana Grande but I'm excited
to see what they do with Wicked James
arenta o 11 number 11 are 11th Super
Chat of the year most anticipated TV
shows hot dog season 2 which will intro
uh craigan the Hunter and the acolyte uh
during filming of acolyte Daphne
King okay that is a very confusing way
of of of putting a
sentence cuz you said I thought you were
saying I thought they were going to
introduce the acolyte into Hot D yeah
yeah I was like oh that's interesting
that there's another version of the
acolyte and then the same year they
releasing the acolyte show okay all
right so during fil of acolyte dapon
King apparently broke four lightsabers
that's nothing Christopher Lambert like
cut his whole like finger off filming
Highlander 2 Michael Ironside broke a
rib because they used real swords per
Christopher Lambert's request of
Highlander 2 would love to see any of
the Highland saying man uh you haven't
seen them Highlanders no they're on my
list that giant ass list I'm sure you
read every inch of of course man um but
dude yeah uh that's a a hot a hot dog
season two I'm really much looking
forward to because I Don't Know Jack
about um the like what's supposed to
happen my I would like to re ends up
happening is like reading a Wikipedia
just does not cut it for me nope I need
the experience so I usually have to
rewatch everything in the middle of all
the other stuff we're doing and so I'm
like rewatching House of the Dragon
season 1's not a problem that's easy uh
but then I had this thought go off in my
brain of that I heard him I ruin some
stuff oh well because there's stuff I
don't remember uh that apparent about
Game of Thrones that that's voted well
for the reaction experience of House of
the Dragon yeah cuz I forget about where
some of this is supposed to go I think
is it about hot dogs Lillian it is it's
about dragons delivering hot dogs it's
about a class of people yeah who have
hot dog delivery dragons and they just
spend all day crushing meat into casings
yeah it's great it's a real uh it's a
real vegan show SC it's a real willly
ENT the public domain you going to do
anything with it we're going to write
our own Steamboat Willie movie now it's
and we're going to write our own we the
Poo movie we're going to Rite a r i
don't know why they haven't done a
crossover yet but they're going to cuz
there's no copyrights anymore they can
I'm only out a high hope for uh acolyte
as well because it's the Star Wars
fandom is one that uh you know I think
they get crapped on so much prod I love
franchises and I love cameos I love all
the Nostalgia I love memberberries I
love I do when they're done right I
think there's a way to do it right some
people see anything remotely close to it
and immediately CH like like take cameos
for example people often roll their eyes
at cameos but I think cameos suck when
that's the point of them you know like
when they use it to get people in seats
versus them actually being the like just
a great cherry on top you know um that
that's when I think they're awful but
but a lot of times cameos can be like
phenomenal you know Easter RGS can be
amazing and freaking um they can be very
fun yeah franchises too and I and I
think like uh Star Wars in particular is
in this weird weird spot right now and
so I'm really hoping that acolyte picks
up and uh our 12th Super Chat of the
Year 12 thank you Elijah that's a really
kind comment Elijah Harris number 12 12
Super Chat Robert
pure Jacob lordy hey you know who that
is I do I haven't seen I don't think
I've seen a performance yet but I know
who he is
everyone's about him looks like the
carton the carton version I'm sure it
won't make one billion but more than 400
million that's a very specific guess I
like that's a good window I think that's
a suitable window of profit there yeah
hot dog taste when when best when
brought by dragons I agree um yeah I
mean I think Jacob a Lordi Jacob a Lordi
he's in the show
Euphoria oh yeah okay really really
abusive he's the not Berry kogan guy in
saltburn which I also haven't seen but I
haven't seen saltburn but I've seen
people in the chat right now talking
about salurn literally four comments in
the chat talking about s uh yeah um I
think I think he has the look and he's
got the talent You've Got The Look he
might be a little too I mean he plays
like a high schooler but I don't know
you just weird to me he comes across a
little too uh Mas like manly for I don't
know Terry mcginness does have this
there's a bit of a feminine touch to
MCAS a slight feminine tou he I I I
don't know how to say this appropriately
but but he looks like like one of those
dudes who like in his late teens early
20s to get money maybe like start in a
couple of like lowbudget adult films
just to you know uh get his feet under
him so like I don't know yeah he's got
that like slight kind of Slender thing
but also like lean muscle and he's got
that kind of em Ruby should play that's
what I mean he's got a feminine thing
about it there something little head
yeah totally toally but he's a great
actor he's like Jacob a Lordi is really
he's one of those guys that you see and
you're like oh man you're stunning and
really talented [__] hate that
welcome Aisha good to see you hey Aisha
what's going on didn't like saltburn
salt bur's divisive it's a divisive
movie the bar kogan's junk is divisive
real apparently I guess that's all I
know about it and I still got to see
promising young woman as well it's the
the director's other movie Emerald finel
pregnant
Barbie as uh who directed it John please
let's move on yes to my most anticipated
TV shows of 2020 it's 13 I just didn't
want to say it because it's unlucky and
now you've cursed the stream people on
the 14th floor you know what floor
you're really on uh Bucky Barnes ATL we
love you appreciate you I hope for a
happy healthy and great new year for you
both I hope for a happier he suffer in
Hell Bucky I that's what I meant to say
I hope for a worst is more sickly I hope
your life is [__] this year Bucky bar
the oldest feeling year yet I want you
to report back saying that there was a
fire in your house love to Pakistan Al P
Pakistan no Bucky Barnes I hope you have
a great year thank you so much thanks
for holding out the chat please leave a
like on this chat we love you buddy
Euphoria as a show needs to never
returned fascinating comment oh I've
only SE I'll I'll watch it now then I
guess damn you know guys your all your
criticisms about saltburn are just
making it sound like a really
interesting watch yeah everything I hear
about it makes me want to see for myself
yeah but thank you Bucky we love you and
appreciate you very much John Lee what
number is it John it's 14 14 John Lee
2020 24 anticipated TV penguin that's on
my list in inin a penguin does look
pretty great yeah and I mean just to see
Colin phoh get the chance to do that
more I'm I'm here for it Invincible
season 2 part two of course I kind of
forgot about him it's oh my God you're
reminding me of so much stuff squid Game
season 2 is coming out this year that's
right is it oh my squid Game season 2
how can we forget someone just reminded
me in the chat doctor who comes back in
May I'm excited I like I love I I found
myself thinking about him really yeah I
like that guy's really good yeah he's a
really good doctor that is the
gratifying thing about Doctor Who is is
no matter with less experience of the CL
the old classics but like no matter how
the era is perceived from a writing
creative standpoint they have always
chosen a worthy actor a compelling actor
to be the doctor and shuti gwa is
perfectly in line with that at least so
far I think yeah no there one episode I
was I was I was hooked and I'm watching
the trailer for what he's got in store
for this coming season I I can't wait to
see more of Doctor Who from him uh Joker
2 Joker to you
know I am I'm heavily considering
leaving Twitter because you go on
Twitter you I have gotten lost in it and
thinking that everything sucks because
like thinking that everyone thinks
everything sucks because of Twitter sure
and you know Twitter it's you got me
convinced people aren't looking forward
to Joker 2 but I think Joker 2 is going
to be a sensational hit I feel like it
will I feel like it's going to be like
massive you got Lady Gaga it man and
even the people hating even the people
hating are going to show up cuz they
have to see what that looks like and I
feel like the thing about having Lady
Gaga and a musical element at that
brings appeals to both as as Harley as
Harley yeah and I think her inclusion
can you know like a joke or two is going
to appeal to everybody who loved and saw
the first Joker but I feel like having
her plus a musical element will bring in
more of the people who weren't for the
first Joker movie you musical aspect uh
you know are as delightful as they you
know Pro portent to be CU I am
constantly sitting here going like man
bring more musical numbers into these
movies uh and and bring a romance we can
care about and for all my gripes about
the first Joker there's stuff that I
feel like you know this could be my
Joker movie if it's done right you know
they should play Bad Romance in their
it's new bong Jun ho with Robert patson
ballerina I don't know the John wi
spin-offs they don't really seem like
they know what they have on their hands
umed I'm excited for I think I mean
ballerina I think people forget that
it's not it's it's John Wick in the
world of John Wick that makes it great
it's not really it's not the freaking
Continental for three
epis yeah I feel like U I don't know I
like Ana de armis if anybody has a chent
she could do it like her like I like
watching goodlooking talented people on
screen guy or girl doesn't matter to me
or whatever your pronoun is like I I
just like watching good-looking talented
people I like watching ugly talented
people yes I like watching good-look
people who aren't
talented
yeah there's plenty of that too it
doesn't matter I want them all also just
comment in the chat what is trap I've
seen the title of this movie I know
nothing about it but let's go to 15 15
Mustafa jav my theory on the Captain
America re-shoot has to do with Sabra
and the conflict in Gaza do you agree if
so what should be the what should the
best route be I think they should
actually take a discernable stance
uh yeah no I I I do think that
um I think that there's constantly
re-shoot and retooling happening for
films all the time I think I give you
the most General [__] answer that
could apply to like probably correct
like Hollywood is notorious for doing
that when it comes to always like kind
of concerned about backlash of any kind
well yeah and especially with something
to this degree they're they're going to
it's very much on their radar at be like
be shot if it's not so they're going to
make the changes that they're going to
make um yeah and from the company for
various reasons I I I could imagine this
Theory being based in reality to some
extent I mean it's a tough situation
because I mean yeah if you're going to
bring your like National Israel
superhero into this and also you know
all that that could possibly like
without a global conflict happening that
about like the the tricky dubious nature
of like creating superheroes who are
like literally supposed to personify
Nations and states and countries um I
don't know I like I I'm conflicted
because I feel like a Captain America of
all Marvel movies AR to be uh you know
have some kind of soop I don't envy
anybody working on the new Captain
America let's just say that John who who
is our
16th
16th who is our 16th Super Chat of the
Year Kaye thank you Kaye for being here
hi John and Greg in terms of TV shows
are we Frozen I don't think so not right
now everything is I'm gonna make 1,00%
frozen oh wow
interesting uh well here let me see what
happens if I just turn the camera
off
on New problems that's what I like in
2024 it's all new
problems uh no how about this before we
do any of that destruction let's just
uh virtual
camera okay it's not registering the
camera yeah yeah that should one second
guys can you hear us though if you can
still hear us we're we're we're still
okay
uh video capture device that's what we
want
okay Cam link
4K damn all right plug it in plug it
back in they can we out here typing
stuff we out here
2024 oh John did you fix it we fixed it
we back it random ass issues on this
that's what I'm talking about doesn't
matter never had that happen but hey
check it out uh in terms of TV shows
Kaye says I know it's not in 2024 but I
cannot wait to see The Last of Us season
2 and celebrate with the whole cast at
the award shows in the next couple of
weeks Greg and Andrew and Tara and John
look out we're gonna mix it up this year
it's GNA be Greg and terara and Andrew
and John and Andrew's gonna spoil it
every second of the way where this
happens also it's just like the Dark
Knight yeah it's going to be good I'm
looking forward to it those were me too
man it's GNA be great we should yeah
I'll do a live stream together when they
do Awards
for the for the show uh dude you're G to
have to really work your ass off to make
sure [__] does not get spoiled for you I
know really work hard I know I'm nervous
about it I hope they change as much as
possible so that things get more and
more
confusing uh we do need more John
reactions oh okay have you not seen deep
blue sea no all right am I going to
watch that alone no no no everybody's
seen it's not as easy to get everyone on
camera as you might think oh I found a
thing that can let us record movie I I'm
excited for last oh Joe Coy's hosted the
Golden Globes oh I'm down okay so uh
yeah the when it comes to what were we
talking about John last season season
two uh last of of season two I I think
that there's an actress who's going to
be getting cast who's already been cast
for it uh a role of care Abby and I'm
just not looking forward to all the [__]
that she's going to unnecessarily get
even though she's just playing a
character oh and getting run off social
media and all yeah because you know how
it goes especially if you're a lady uh
you know that [__] goes down they're
like you're real to me and I hate
you you represent all the women I can't
say this to in my actual life so uh yeah
man I'm looking forward to but more
shark movie reactions I agree thank you
Kay that's a very generous Super Chat
thank down I haven't seen any of the
Jaws sequels oh my God wait a minute
hold on a second I lost count that's 12
13 14 15 16 17th Super Chat of the Year
Kiana Chanel hi Kiana hey hey hey she
says happy New Year handsome Greg thank
you for directing that just at me
excited to see more from y'all oh
handsome
Greg well it's handsome Rob yeah Rob Rob
yeah it's the green like oh I'll find
some Rob oh hey oh I'm not very B yeah
okay yeah that movie could be better now
but anyway happy New Year to you Happy
New Year to you for the love and support
thank you are we buffering again first
tweets oh I hope not no it says we're
excellent and I always believe what
YouTube say yeah [__] YouTube I mean
you know I just look over to the left
and I see your little screen and I'm
like we're doing all right we're right
here this how I'm talking to you guys
yeah look out now
the Golden Globes are on
Sunday oh my god really already we
should reacted and be like I haven't
seen any of this
[__] yeah I've been saving all these
movies for later uh happy early birthday
Morning Star who is our 17th Super Chat
of the Year John Kiana Chanel is but
who's number 18 no wasn't she 16 no
Kaylee was 16 are you sure yeah we did
the count hold on okay cuz Bucky was 13
right Bucky 13 14 15
16 17 oh you're right who's our 18th
Super Chat of the Year hey we got
stubble M shave to things we never do
but always have you get what I mean
anyway stubble I'm looking forward to
megalopolis a passion project it's a
cross of Julius Caesar and Blade Runner
by the guy who made Apocalypse Now and
the godf father damn copel is coming
back that's right it's written directed
and produced by him wow Stars Adam
Driver Forest Whitaker John voy Lawrence
Fishman Aubrey Plaza shy lauff Jason
schwarzman Talia Shire returning that's
cool not bad Dusty H uh Jean Carlo
Esposito DB Sweeney look out and Natalie
Emanuel I know that name okay here's the
plot in New York a woman is divided
between loyalties to her father who has
a classical view of society and an
architect lover who is more Progressive
and ready for the future wants to
rebuild New York City as a Utopia
following a devastating disaster this
sounds like a very ambitious movie I
know I'm nervous and if anyone knows
franch for cop's work as of late you
know it's going to be top-notch material
right here yes you know all these people
didn't just agree because it's Franc for
cop recent fil so let's make it hey oh
hey one of our matches is live right now
on The Showdown YouTube channel so if
you get bored you can go watch that who
are we playing don't tell tell me don't
go to it no that sounds cool stuff I'm
I'm interested I hope it's good man it
may be great if his last movie I'm
assuming it's going to be his last
because he's like maybe it'll bring him
back 90 and you know he's not exactly
looking the healthiest what was this
previous movie at the flower Moon that's
right of course terrible film with
Christian
Bale uh number 19 the c kid that's where
we're at where are you guys from I'm
from here John's from down street I'm
from down the street from up the street
I'm from 10 minutes a away yes yeah yeah
we're all neighbors here yeah man in the
biggest uh City amalgam grew up here in
Los Angeles uh born and raised in the
valley yeah see celebrities every day
yeah I saw Jason Stam in an arklite once
so did I hey I think we're at the same
screening
oh um I see like a famous person every
day
just the other day saw Adam Driver
masturbating it's
crazy saw Eddie M Murphy taking a dump
on the side yeah yeah the celebrities is
treated like it's a private bathroom and
we just take photos and it's a great
time yeah absolutely it's a great time
the best time I did see hash I'm joher I
saw William H Macy in an old timey
pickup truck once and I saw it I saw him
uh doing that as a job moving someone's
truck sure I believe Towing it
he hasn't been working no he's not in
enough things ja Jackie Mason number 20
number 20 20 love my space babies tea I
got for Christmas any chance you guys
will be at megga Con in Orlando next
month I'm sending John I'm going be
there John's gonna go to Mega con join
me for Megacon I will be hosting a live
panel solo by myself where I imagine
what Greg and Koy would have said on the
panel and I recited to
you I think that would be great we not
oh my God you got to see Sophia Copa are
we lagging again why are we always
lagging that's our thing this is our new
thing for John is married to his long
hair I am um yeah so um the the I would
love to do some black exploitation films
are you kidding me if that was a lane we
could occupy I would be there all day
what I would love to
do is uh a real live Bel on the lives
because I I I really other than this uh
crazy lag that's been happening the
entire time normally these streams are
just smooth and a lot of fun and if
they're not smooth they're wacky and and
and I think for those who have seen us
at a live show I think you'll see that
they're very different than what other
people usually get from a live show
absolutely I feel like it's it's not
your typical I I think that would be um
I I I would love to do a lot God we keep
lagging oh no it was going so well no
and I see it on the screen it keeps
happening the whole time John it's
really pissing me off no it's pissing me
off too well you wanted to stream back
here never again learn how to I I'll
redo all this on the streamlabs version
PJ you might see us in person I'm
obsessed 21 your average person hey it's
about time we met you it's good to see
you hold on
all right we got it we well I want I
need to see we're quiet
John all right looks like we're back
sure let's see how this is going yes as
the thing fluctuates your average person
what are your thoughts on Sonic 3 coming
out later this
year um my thoughts on Sonic 3 coming
out later this year are that when it
comes out out I will be waiting for it
to come out a video Dem so I can watch
it here with you guys yeah baby we
reacted to the P It's the weird conflict
we've run into as of late of uh it's
it's like again a first world problem to
the firstest degree you can imagine if
there was a number above
one I would it would be one of the of
like sometimes it is like I I saw
Godzilla minus one
ah Lu John has to react to it is he
covered Shin Godzilla hey so he has to
stay here and watch it in on a big TV a
loser okay they'll you're a loser you're
a loser don't you feel like an idiot
don't you feel like a loser J I do I do
no that's what I mean by uh like this
the like it's such a first world problem
because I mean like I I I love the movie
by the way I think it's a like probably
the best movie of the year I love the
movie
and I cuz I love going to the theaters I
do mhm but
honestly these days it's a pain in the
ass to like theaters like o the minus
one I saw in the theaters when there was
like five people there IMAX that was
perfect yes cuz whenever there's more
than that there's someone on their phone
or they they're like I'm not on my phone
I'm on my my bright ass Apple watch yeah
[__] checking my text messages I'm
like how is I'm like brightness all the
way down this hurts yeah and people
everywhere I see using their phone in
the theater are like let me get this can
I get this brighter than it actually
offers do you see my hand up here people
needed to hear my riff I put my hand up
there because that means we're lagging
John I know I know I
know but it picks that [__]
up old
time because when it's lagging here it's
behind the moment it's there's a delay
it's not that much like the chat is more
behind than it than we are with the
delay I know I can do this you can do
you I can control everything I have the
pow just wait yes yes yes it's okay this
will be
yes 16 17 okay 18 19 20 21 our 2 second
Super Chat of the Year woo
Tim Tim Tim the greatest
character Legacy Charlie I love when
definitely know they mean it I like that
Tim well I'm biased that's probably
going to make Olivia uncomfortable oh no
I can't I can't even talk to gay guys
now oh you talk women I can't talk to
gay guys you got to talk talk to asexual
people I got to talk to people I got to
talk to to I got to talk to Unix now is
there is there an app and it wouldn't be
a dating app but just an app can't do
only interested in platonic interactions
uh when s man season 2 comes around we
might consider doing Sam man season one
reaction shows
especially like if we start like for
some reason Reacher was the the only
Oddball and our season one reactions
doing those a year late did Super
superiorly better than season 2 in real
time any of season two is done for
us but you just said Denzel's in the
cast so maybe it's on my list the first
Gladiator is one of my favorite oh my
God the lag I know and it's weird the
first Gladiator is one of my favorite
movies of all time
sure it's not man it's okay like like we
we have like we pay for the most
expensive internet we could pay for like
we should be able to have more than $1
device and it's only meant for this one
location there is so there should be
theoretically there should be less
stream issues than if we were in the
other spot there is the possibility that
this is a YouTube problem there not not
to take the blame off but there is a
possibility that maybe this is a YouTube
server issue no I blame us
definitely uh you know because even when
the stream is excellent on their
analytics it's still like lagging a bit
so I don't know I don't know man but it
could be YouTube I don't know some
people are saying uh YouTube's having
problems I've seen multiple people in
the chat say YouTube is having problems
so that's great well that's why I want
to switch to Twitch guys if we went to
Twitch would you guys follow us over
there too I was thinking of going to
Twitch we can figure that um anyway uh
yeah I mean Gladiator 2
though
okay so a lot people are very supported
with the twitch switch surprisingly um
we should create please switch to wow uh
yeah no we like we've I've talked about
it with John about like I'd love to go I
just go to Twitch because I feel like
that's more accustomed for live streams
and we love live streaming second I
leave here today
I'm I would love to do I wouldn't mind
switching it it's just like our audience
is all here so you know well what we can
do is like I wasn't defending
transphobic comedians I was defending
the part where they completely took
something where I was like that is not
what happened Dave yeah Dave Chappelle
wasn't the actual point subject of that
senent it was varieties bending of
things to create Sensational headlines
were known to do that lately I was
watching a very fascinating video about
about Dave Chappelle and all that stuff
on the FD signifier Channel go check his
[__] out great video essayist oh we can
simoc cast to Twitch that's another one
too oh sure and yeah that might be the
clips out posting them oh Myspace let's
go to Myspace Myspace let's stream on
MySpace Tom's still there so yeah I
don't really know what like when you
hear Gladiator 2 like when you think
Gladiator you think Russell Crow I know
bottom line that's what you think
Maximus
Decimus Maximus simus Meridius um so you
think Russell crow like he's the
Gladiator
gu and so to not it like it's not based
it's not a true story uh so the world
that took place in that historical piece
doing a historical fiction riffing on
some parts of history that are true blah
blah blah it to me I guess I don't maybe
if I watched the movie again I'd be
interested in a gladiator too but right
now I'm like you killed off the
Gladiator like it that's his it's the
it's the movie is his story it's
maximus's story yeah could
return the sun could carry on oh no no
Sun's totally Dead uh that's part of the
plot friend you have a secret J hansu um
like I don't know what Denzel's role
will be like I'm I'm I'm looking forward
to it just because just because it is uh
you know it's Denzel and and Ridley
Scott together Ridley Scott and and
Russell Crow and then Russell scow
Russell Crow Denzel and Ridley Scott did
American Gangster and now Russell Crow
won't be back for Gladiator and and
Denzel Washington will be in there so
kind of an interesting trajectory there
does have a stacked cast they're trying
to replace Russell Crow with 20 other
people Denzel Pedro Pascal Connie neelen
Paul Mescal who everyone loves you can
that's what I mean like it doesn't sound
like Gladiator 2 to me J Quin it seems
like they're doing a movie that's within
the Gladiator world yeah it feel like it
could be great you know like it's funny
to me true DMV for life as the guy who
just said I love franchises Easter eggs
and cameos You Love and Hate Everything
equally Greg you are impossible to
please and yet somehow you love
everything and that's just who you are
accept it the internet sees you for what
you're I love everything and have no
criticisms that's that's ironic yeah
isn't that ironic I've taken such a turn
I know it yeah I I agree it's like
there's a it's weird it's weird to be
excited and optimistic about beetle to
and like a little suspect of gladiator
to cuz like Ridley just stays working
and makes like 100 movies a year and you
know they vary in quality some are
pretty great some
are uh and within that Paradigm I am
sort of like I don't I don't know I'm
I'm exactly with you I'm like Ridley
Scott is a world-class filmmaker he's a
veteran he's got a great cast assembled
but like what you associate with a movie
like Gladiator is those specific people
so it's basically like a GL Gladiator 2
to me is like a blank slate and it's
only Gladiator 2 because we're going
back to these particular times in
history but like what is really going to
tie it to the first movie in a
meaningful way I don't feel like you
need to even call Gladiator 2 I think
with a cast like this with a director
like that yeah and we all know Ridley
Scott movies they're all huge call it
the Coliseum or something or Gladius
yeah um let's go here should play Iron
Fist I love your your iron fist
voice dance for me why are you blaming
me for it I've tried to fix this stream
man yeah I've tried to fix the stream I
tried but I didn't try for real I tried
to make it worse DMV for Life he's
saying I used to be ha more happy and
nice your Israel now check this
out [__] you no look out look out Coy oh
damn ouch you're gone now oh you're
you've been hidden away
yeah anything that reminds me of what
some [__] someone would say on
Twitter they're
gone simple as that get out of here Elon
something simple as that gladi 2 though
good
com5 oh my uh what is this
20 hold on a minute okay so so Keana was
17 right 18 19 20 21 22 was Tim 23 oh
their dude the Wesley Kano art the best
real reaction bless bless you my friend
thank you for the love and support and
for uh you know assessing Us in the
superlative I appreciate Wesley Kano
Kano is a is a good rapper guys don't I
appreciate everyone who everyone who's
in the chat who's been like coming to my
defense right now and I want to say that
it's okay what I realized
lately is after having some Twitter
threads about me recently I was like
looking at other social media people and
I realize the key to success is you got
to become a fullblown sociopath sure you
got to have complete and other
Shameless yes feel and if people hate
you find a way to monetize that find a
way rage bait to um utilize that give
more to it yes just looking at what a
lot of people do like you I see like
especially people like the ones who for
come from like you see it with YouTubers
but you'll especially see it with people
who form from Tik Tok and twitch just
the the most Shameless [__] ever doesn't
matter what no matter how much they just
they're never wrong and they'll only
admit when they're wrong if it's
starting to affect their
monetary so that's what conviction means
like I just see like you know I've seen
threads about me it just like oh my God
he just pretends to be shocked and and
surprised and it's fake then I'm balling
on camera and people and I see a threat
about me Balling on camera and like ah
he just
snot red nose like come on man yeah it's
a perance of Life Time right there like
that that means I'm a good actor you
dumbass yeah nobody had to blow anything
in what you going to say that about me
on Twitter to [__] say that yeah it's
just to me it's like just um recently
until I had to look up real Rejects and
monitor or something and I came across
some threads and you see these people
like crapping on me and the part of it
that surprised me is why didn't they at
me why didn't you add me like if you're
going to do this add me don't don't just
just make a threat and and engage and
then not at me then that being way too
cly about it sure yeah I mean yeah
that's a bold that is a bold statement
24 it's not bold it's just like [__]
don't be a coward just just at me no no
I agree with that but I'm saying bold in
the sense that you know like I also
understand just not wanting to hear that
noise and not want it to invade your at
boox yeah yeah but uh but no I
appreciate your your Gusto and your grit
no no d i just blocked whoever was being
a dick in the chat but I um anyway
so Bryce
Ratliff what number is he 24 for 244 24
for 2024 and he is the F his first Super
Chat
yes and my God you think this isn't
already on the list I was going to do it
to do them with Roxy and then I already
put the thing is I feel really bad when
I bring someone on here oh my God the
streamlabs have you not been
looking yeah I could also look too John
but I'm going to blame you I'm going to
blame you you don't need to do anything
you're good as you
are hey oh I've seen campia exposed I
know what YouTube channel you're talking
about
yeah the whole Channel just dedicated
to of one oh sorry I was just checking
this out to see what it looked like but
I'll change it back sorry it's okay is
good great thumbnail by the way
appreciate it thank you I worked on it
this morning you did you did a great job
while John put us on this lagging
internet you know that's Jon's
contribution I don't do [__]
ever I don't care about anything so
anyway uh yeah we want to cover it but I
just keep hearing that people constantly
get demonetized for it and you guys got
understand like the movie reactions
it's always such a like I just did
orphan with uh with Roxy and I didn't
realize like just the cont there's this
whole thing that happened where where
John and roxxy's Gremlins video got uh a
yellow dollar bill sign meaning there's
like inappropriate stuff in here and
you're not going to get ads and I had to
hit up JN I'm like was there something
in this video that you guys said because
because it's Gremlins this movie's PG
like what happened and even at its worst
it helped create
PG-13 so it's like not that hardcore
yeah so I was like what happened here
because we we get hit with it like for
the most weird [__] and it's a bummer
only because well they'll take but no
they do they take a lot of time yeah and
uh there's at least that's why the end
of every month we look tired to sure
sure um and so yeah that's the one part
a terrifier that has uh got me trepid
dious is I'm like fo I feel like it's
going to take so much work to put it
together and it's not even be able to be
monetized that's why we got to get on
nebula so that we could be I mean cuz
cuz part of me like terrifier sounds
like a lot of fun and part of me is like
I would love to do like reactions to
like extreme films or like those films
where it's like a challenge like watch a
seran film and see if you can make it
through uh but yeah that would be it
would be very hard under this paradigm
and terrifier for like as popular and
popular culture as those movies are like
yeah the whole point seems to be to be
gleefully gory and disgusting and pulpy
and all that stuff yeah but even though
we knew people are talking about in the
chat about like yeah p in the80s was
iffy a th% sure the thing is though like
we I'm always
aware I'm always aware that sh's going
to be F the only thing I could think of
with Gremlins is there's one character
with like a very dark backstory but you
know I don't know yeah
I don't know oh VI rocks got some g-u
that's what I love to hear anyway John
who's our 25th Super Chat fuel uh let's
see all right John that's what I think
there's no cats back here Robo 96 and
then we got to read that streamlab yes
we do um I if anyone on the channel
hasn't seen um thank you Robin I6 anyone
the channel hasn't seen them a couple of
you guys are G do reaction of the Han
Lector Trilogy with Anthony Hopkins and
also Band of Brothers by the way Madam
Webb is the most midl looking thing ever
I'll take a mid I got to say you know
like it looked fine and fun but koi
being over the moon about it I was like
I don't know what drug you are on right
now man because the way you eat up this
Sony [__] mind boggles me he'll be so
honest about the way like an MCU
property Mak is making him feel but for
some reason them Sony properties CO's
like it's the night
I get what he's getting at I think he
could maybe articulate it slightly more
clearly but but I get what he's getting
at and then like I'm gonna have fun
probably because it you know because of
the meme certainly uh but yeah it is
fascinating to to be
like yeah yeah Sony presents an
interesting quadrant of Ko's brain and
here's the thing with the Madam web
thing I'm always I know Sydney Sweeney
something isn't she Michelle um the
thing about Madam web love there are
three Sony Spider-Man movies coming out
this year yeah you got Craven you got oh
my God the [__]
lag you got Craven you got Venom 3 and
you got um uh Madam web and I'm Madam 3
oh Venom 3 sorry fully you say You're
such a smart ass no I was like what is
this third movie oh cuz I'd also
forgotten Venom 3 was coming out such
smart I wasn't trying to be you're such
a smart not this time you say it was
such a smart you sound like Bill Maher
oh no that's who you that's who you
remind me of drawn behind the scenes
don't care for Bill Bill
Mah no me Bill
Bird Coy Bill Dave
[Laughter]
Bill who you go but the thing is
I no matter how bad some these Sony
Spider-Man movies look I'm always gonna
be there to watch that cuz there is
something I get see the thing is I I am
fascinated by how KY assesses these
movies but I do share that Spirit of
like it's going to be fun is probably
going to be a little wild and it's going
to be at least a bit different from
whatever Marvel's doing even if whatever
that is isn't like objectively good
cinema like it it'll probably be pretty
fun like I don't know Sony seems to have
this this nice niche where they're like
we're playing fast and loose but you
know we know how to at least have some
fun like Mor is could have been worse
and boring yeah uh so yeah Greg is know
what it is look poo Pride okay hold on
we're lagging it's okay but it's going
to pick up it's it's lagging before you
said like you you will it will pick up
you saying we don't know we don't know
yeah cuz I I I lip the last one and it
stopped before you started saying the
thing that you stopped during saying so
well there's something about Joe Koy
where I'm Filipino panoi Pride all the
way it's amazing to see the career he's
had I still feel like I wouldn't be
surprised if he got canceled for some
[__] he's got that Vibe oh no there's a
Vibe no what does describe the vibe I
you're just like if someone if some
woman came out and said some [__] about
him I'd be like yeah I saw that I feel
it I felt it before you had said
anything lady like you just
got let me see I'm going to run a test
here I'm going to see if if I uh pull it
up on the phone if it lags at the same
time yours does or if uh sorry about the
long lag so according to you the
internet connection is excellent yeah
according to what they're saying so I I
really do think this is a YouTube issue
yeah because our our speeds have been
pretty our internet speed we just ran a
a speed test it's really fast um we got
it just for this one loc like there's a
separate internet just for this one
location yeah there's nothing feeding
off of it but this so it's fast back
here on top of that too YouTube is
saying the connection is excellent so I
think it's a YouTube Problem um and yeah
so it's Joe Koy torpedoing this dream
absolutely let him you
he's our 26 Super Chat uh oh my God the
lag it's okay it's not lagging on my
phone though that's the thing is it
still
going so like I I I don't I don't know
what to make of this well whenever I'm
saying there's a lag every people are
also affirming that in the chat you know
so when're
lagged as well on the
video okay myen Eko thank you so much
for being our 26th Super Chat of the
Year any promising horror movies coming
out this year I hear great things about
that terrifier franchise oh people love
it going to be Christmas terrified I'm
really looking forward to nasat to it's
from Robert edar who uh directed The
Witch uh um the Northman yes and now
he's doing nasat so you know that if
there's one thing thing is it lagging
for you I thought you had it John I did
but now I pulled up my list it's
currently not lagging it's okay if
there's one thing that I feel like um
that Robert Edgar goes for is
authenticity with the dialogue and for
Nas forat 2 which originally came to the
Silver Screen as a black and white
silent film to then be going it I don't
think it's G to feel like a
modernday horror movie whatsoever I feel
like V is going to have a great trailer
and a really disappointing audience
score because of how authentic it's
going to be to the time period so that's
my personal pick I don't know why John
doesn't like it but hey that's just me
man hey we got saw 11 in 2024 we got ma
uh I mean Godzilla X Kong kind of counts
uh Alien ramulus as much as I lament not
living on the Neil Blom Camp alien movie
timeline I am excited to see what fed
Alvarez does with that and Shelby
Oaks Chris stuckman movie comes out this
year yeah supported on patreon yeah look
at that I mean on Kickstarter do you
Twisters I mean you can now um I mean
there are more actually I have an
infographic saved of all the horror
releases of 2024 but those are the ones
that popped into my mind uh yeah uh ight
shyamalan's daughter's doing a movie
what is she really yeah the trailer's
going to say from the of ight sh
oh from the producer of the six s uh
Lisa Frankenstein Winnie the Pooh Blood
and Honey Honey 2 imaginary Ghostbusters
the first Omen Godzilla X Kong return to
Silent Hill horror scope The Strangers
the Watchers a quiet place day one trap
speak no evil I guess they're just
remaking that alien Romulus Beetle Juice
the one I won't mention smile 2 Wolfman
terrifier Ru Witch Board Maxine Salem's
Lot Shelby
Oaks that's what I horror news put out
to look forward to and thanks I
appreciate that yeah you didn't mention
night swim Lisa Frankenstein is directed
by Robin Williams daughter look at that
thank you J um Justin clowater uh thank
you so much for being our
27th 28th 28th 28 28th Super Chat of the
Year best and worst theater experience
of 2023 oh wow good question best leader
experience Godzilla minus one because
there was barely anyone there and I
could watch an IMAX
fantastic um worst theater experience
Halloween and was that last
year no no it wasn't no that was the end
of 2022 that was that was still one of
the worst experiences I've ever had a I
wonder what the uh I didn't really go to
the theaters that much in 202 23 I can't
really think of a bad theater experience
I don't really have a bad one I don't
think uh I mean I remember my favorite
theater experiences I think were kind of
with older movies like I I went to a
place called um the Oldtown Music Hall
to see Ed Wood which is my favorite like
a worlitzer Oregon and they play like a
play some music and they do like a sing
along and show a cartoon it's like an
old timey place for an old timey
experience when they show silent movies
they play music live during the M uh so
that was really cool and uh and going to
see Silent Hill uh at the newbev was
very fun because it had been a while
since I had seen it it was a midnight
show you know the crowd was about it and
it really
highlighted both the the stuff that
movie is doing that I'm like you didn't
have to put in all this effort and I
love that you did and also the stuff the
movie is doing where you're like this is
totally a midnight like I've I've rarely
seen a movie that that c crosses the
line between midnight movie cheesiness
but also like legitimately cool
atmospheric film making like kind of in
equal measure um so that was a cool it
was cool to see the movie and have all
that highlighted through the experience
uh and to see all that on uh you know 35
millimeter was pretty sick as well I
have not seen heart thought damn that's
good to hear John let's move on to our
29th Super Chat no no no really quick
let's see what that that that Infamous
streamlab is oh yes yes I'll switch to
the
thing and ni so different we're GNA go
over here and we're gonna magnify oh no
it's magnified right all
right we got Seth ARP happy New Year
guys thank you for being here Seth can't
wait for Deadpool 3 I was going to make
a joke but I I don't feel like getting
this stream demonetized I feel like Ryan
will do US Post post Super Bowl trailer
release like he did a teaser after
d23 also feel the hype is big enough but
they don't need to do much marketing but
what do you hope to see in the teasers
that's a great question there Seth I
want to see a bunch of [__] that's not
actually in the movie uh yeah
legitimately I think that would be a
solid choice I think it would be funny
if they just used a collection of all
the leaked footage that had been going
around yeah yes and uh and just a big
thing of Ryan Reynolds just being like
why why did you do this to us I don't
think we need to see I I feel like the
trailers for this can be surprisingly
mysterious and comedic at the same time
I would love that like I I think uh
Deadpool one and two their trailers
really laid out like what the plot of it
was going to be they can really write a
dangerous line into showing us too much
and when I think that we're already sold
like people everyone's already sold on
this movie even if the trailer comes out
it doesn't even look great yeah we're
still going to watch it it's one of
those movies just like how can you not
see this
movie you know it's
a um don't leave the stream can um
there's so much to look forward to that
I I I honestly just kind of hope that
they keep it to a bare minimum I know
it's like a cheap answer here sure I
just don't think they need to show us
anything really you know
yeah because like like like Hugh Jackman
and Deadpool fighting like that's that's
going around for months now and and
you're just like yeah I know that's
probably going to happen in like act two
before they [__] team up you know
like I I highly doubt that's like
towards the finale I imagine that's
that's like a midpoint fight or a break
into act two fight before they before uh
I'd be very surprised if it's not you
know yeah especially with how much it
look to be engaging in that fight sure
so yeah I feel like it's an interesting
op like part of me is like also the only
MCU movie MCU specific movie of 2023
which is a great lovely opportunity I am
very happy they have
taken space am definely space amount and
plus like for what the movie portends to
be you know the prospect of again
Deadpool's homecoming but also this
crazy wild meta multiple time Adventure
like I feel like that's a perfect movie
to have just be the one for the year you
know you know you know I think random
May in the chat I think I think we need
to not worry about um the cam I think
the cameos will all be done in good just
at even if they are just there for fan
service I think they'll be self-aware to
acknowledge even if it's just that for
Deadpool 3 especially I would agree you
know alrighty let's move on let's move
along do
let's just W we're here make sure that
uh why yeah just cuz man why not why not
you know what I'm saying because I got
to work on a whole video today I got
other people who are going to show up
here go no get the hell out of here
right this minute I know John Michelle
number
29 Michelle who's always 30 because we
just did the stream L does that count as
2 okay no 29 no no no Seth is our first
stream Dream lab of the Year number one
Seth well done well done Seth not not
2020 for pitching a series where JN
reacts to his fave and new horror movies
also happy 2024 looking forward to
seeing all the content to come this year
I mean I would be thrilled it's just a
matter of if it works with every other
consideration John's the biggest horror
fici AO at the same time he acts like
the most terrified
yeah CU shit's effective if it's good
it's effective no John I'm Twitter yes
of course yes you you must become
desensitized otherwise you're not into
it I must become a sociopath yes I must
become a detached emotionless husk who
just thinks all this is normal why do
you think it's all Elon Musk yeah guy's
brilliant that's why he built space he
he found space he found space we did not
know about space until Elon Musk no he
put FL on the
moon well that part's not true he's
going to cover the moon in a filter that
makes it look found moon but he didn't
put the he didn't he's going to build
the first X logo we thought it was the
Sun going to sleep and then we realized
oh giant rock floats by every night I
can't adopt you right now rald why not
um yeah I would love for John to watch
some horror movies i' love watching hor
because he doesn't watch that many but
he acts like he does does I did and now
I now anything I haven't seen I'm like
should I hold
up cuz I like being able to be minus one
in the theaters I'm like I'm excited to
watch with like saw 10 was the test
watch cuz I was like this is the movie
where it's like if any movie I was anal
about seeing in the theaters
theoretically it should be this one but
even that I was like no I'm excited for
the video it's going to be good I'm fine
it's going to be fun Laura remembers me
roasting you on the Doctor Who reactions
yes there's going to be a point where
you're going to see Greg reaching into
the bottom of the barrel this
year with I Haven seen anything because
I'm like looking at I got a list of like
a whole bunch of other people's movie
everyone who comes here and stuff and
it's a lot of always kind of figure out
who to pair and blah blah blah it's like
a lot of like this brain work of [__]
the the
the but for me for like like the movies
I haven't seen the biggest movies I
haven't seen I'm like I've already
covered most of the biggest movies I
haven't
seen sometimes they surprise me I'm like
oh [__] it's Wy wono one did well Percy
Jackson did really well um you know but
in terms of like ones that I know are
big uh that I'm I'm like almost done
except for ones that I'm I I obviously
didn't see in 2023 like Grand Turismo
it's going to be huge it's going to be
the biggest one we've done this year
yeah and then we're going to start
streaming Gran Turismo games um become
the Gran Turismo rejects the uh uh uh
what else haven't we not seen 2023
Aquaman didn't I just didn't Aquaman
Wonka plain and simple that was a pure
case of I have no time to go to theaters
and watch this movie you didn't want to
spend extra time producing a video I
don't have time to I mean I can maybe go
watch it maybe but there's no way can
make a video about this so yeah and so
to our
luck I'll be reacting to it with
Roxy no no no no I'm just joking John my
my man I'm joking John we'll watch
together you look like Jason mimoa I
know I owe it to the people I'm gonna
get so jacked by then I'm G to start
lifting VI Brocks number 30 30 Gundam
Seed Freedom number 2024 for me what is
that is it a new Gundam anime or is it
something else Gundam
Seed oh yeah Mo Gundam Seed is an anime
series um hey I used to love Gundam Wing
I would love to check back in with the
show and see where it's at now now you
sometimes like what uh I've been trying
to get through Cowboy
bbop talked to John him four years yeah
I know yeah yeah I don't I don't
I'm always so like I have a million
things I perceive needing to do so the
time I spend actually just sitting down
going I'm gonna watch a thing is very
minimal yeah I'm hoping in 2024 that
will change I know I know and I think
about
that I look back and I'm like yeah
breaking this down would have been easy
and not even just for like work or
research but like you know just like
breaking this down in a manageable way
so that I can enjoy it would have been
easy but uh oh that's a great my brain
doesn't work that way you keep talking I
love this idea oh hey I love ideas as
well number thir eight Productions you
you almost look like the funme
Productions logo is it you maybe either
way the boys are back happy New Year
this year seems like it's going to be a
bit of a dud with all the delays but do
you guys predict any Saving Grace from
TV or movies that'll be really popular
in
2024 it's a great question I I hope it's
something no one's really thinking about
or or that isn't like one of the hype
properties that just like comes out of
nowhere and uh and yeah that like really
grabs people um I hope you know what I I
am looking forward
to uh a24 I think acquired has been
hotel which is an animated project you
know 2D animated project musical Etc
it's always kind of under threat of some
kind and uh from what I understand this
is you know like a a an in independ or
at least initially independent and like
you know uh highly produced piece um and
every Glimpse I've seen has been cool so
I would love for something like that to
pop off or whatever um I mean you know
House of the Dragon will be fine because
they didn't have to stop with a bang and
like really galvanizes or gets people
excited like I feel like there's a lot
of potential for that
and like it could have both the cool
[__] but also like the sardonic weird
humorous [__] that you want um but I
don't I mean my prediction is I think
squid Game season 2 will be big I you it
won't be I feel like what are you out of
your mind with like the game show I I
don't know what point in the Stream is
this I cannot wait to play this back so
I can constantly rub it in John's face
you're probably going to be right when
the numbers come in and everyone's like
this is the biggest SE don't expect it
to be bigger than the first one it's
going to be the biggest thing ever I
feel like stranger things season five
that'll be huge that'll be already came
out no five why would it be
bigger uh it's really good unless it's
really good they never planned they
never planed to do a season two and even
without strikes in America it's taken a
long time and I feel like what one thing
we have seen in the past couple years is
that things except unless you're Reacher
I guess like things that take a long
time to come back after a really
acclaimed season unless you're a
stranger things with multiple Seasons
worth of momentum built up behind you I
feel like that does hurt these shows
that because we are coming out of a
paradigm where we used to be like okay
every year as long as the show's been
picked up every year it'll drop new
episodes sure whereas now it could be
three years who knows you know oh Kerber
enthusiasm final season n it's gonna be
a Talk of the Town
yeah like Larry's gonna do something
that you know gets him in trouble It
embarrasses himself and it's going
to it's going to end negatively for him
it's going to be cring it's gonna be bad
it's GNA be really bad be bad but it'll
be good bad be bad yeah anyway John
let's move on let's move on to number
32 Rob Zombie Godzilla 518 thanks bud
Deadpool 3 and Godzilla times Kong are
my most anticipated movies not just of
2024 so Godzilla X
Kong when I rewatch Godzilla versus Kong
in preparation just for the trailer
yes I couldn't believe it I was like
Gods the AL Kongs would be the greatest
movie of all time I hope so it just
looks like they yes the Millie Bobby
Brown Brian Tyreek Henry story is like
freaking Bland and
boring God damn it
what what what does his note
say it's the same same [__] it's the
same wasting my time but yeah every time
I watch it are we like way Frozen okay
every the it seems like they have really
learned their lesson of what worked from
the first one and are just going to zero
in completely in on it yeah and give us
more of what we want knowing
that like to get Adam Wingard back I
think was such a smart choice as well
because for a guy he did a excellent
[__] job yeah like on capturing Kong
especially human making Kong a real
character the monster mashup fights were
excellent in that film and now that he
got his feet wet with knowing how to
work with this visual effects you can
really get a vision around it it already
looks like more focused and has more of
a life about it in a way that just seems
purposeful off the trailer alone sure so
yeah I I I think the one detriment
Godzilla X Kong has right now is only
the fact that Godzilla minus one is a
phenomenal film and has really pierced
the Zeitgeist in a way that I don't
think anyone really anticipated for it
to do because it's Godzilla minus one
sort of set this standard of you can do
like a genuinely amazing film that's not
just built off of a fun and whereas the
monster verse is like ah humans suck but
man those monster fights are freaking
fun stop trying to make a great film and
just make you fun
whereas like but yeah whereas uh it
Godzilla m x
Kong they have this opportunity where
the the monsters really are the
protagonist that's at least what the
trailer is pitching me on yeah is that
the monsters themselves are the
characters yeah and the humans will be
secondary mhm would I like good human
characters absolutely not here but it's
probably not a likely
scenario and I think when with with this
trailer it helps I think what's cool
about the monster verses it helps to
separate itself from like because like
the the Godzilla movies the ones from
Japan the Toho the actual Toho ones deal
with the nuclear blast that makes
Godzilla and all that [__] and then the
monsterverse ones are like we have
Hollow Earth in this other realm and one
is Monarch one is like way more
allegorically arounded and the other
ones is like Pure Fantasy yeah and the
American ones are this Pure Fantasy
approach and it looks like we're finally
getting one that's just going to so
embrace it like there's this whole
civilization in the hollow Earth uh and
I'm going to give you guys this little
spoiler John and I watched the latest
episode of Monarch and and we have been
insanely up and down on this show yes
like there are some episodes that we
just I can't like we they cannot say
anything about it I will risk it by
saying it's great it it is an actual
like great episode that we were there
just go this this whole episode's
freaking great it's a great episode so I
love um I I I think it's really cool how
the monsterverse we don't often look at
it as like a Cinematic Universe but it
is we only we DC's got in development
and the MCU but the monster verse is
really pulling it off right now uh so I
think Godzilla X Kong could surpass
Godzilla versus Kong I think it could I
think yeah like it's the monsterverse
has been a fascinating journey of
watching them work out in real time how
these movies should come across because
Godzilla it makes a lot of sense like
the first one starts with like okay this
is pretty character-based and is going
with the old you know we're glimpsing
Godzilla in increasing little bursts
until the end and then yeah it's like
you get a perfect director or
theoretically in uh Michael D and then
yeah you kind of watch is like okay king
of the monsters we're trying to figure
out what the balance is and we're not
quite getting it but the monster stuff's
good so this is still making money and
then you go to yeah Godzilla versus Kong
which which manages to yeah be like the
most agreeable while still being you
know like a be movie and I feel like
yeah this one could rise to the heights
of fun if they just pitch it proportion
proportionately and and there's one
thing that Adam Winger has said that I
don't always love to hear but in this
case I think bodess decently which is
that thing of like there are whole
sequences that are just completely
animated that are just the monsters
doing their things for multiple minutes
on end uh where you don't even have like
real humans to worry about and while
part of me is like I don't think the
lesson we should take from this is just
like give up on human characters
altogether at the same time I am like
but this that Bridges the gap between
watching something animated and watching
something live in a way that's not like
The Lion King reboot where you know
you're having that debate the whole time
instead of watching the movie uh but
yeah I think it'll be I hope it's good I
don't know like Adam Wingard I'm
surprised that he cracked the code or at
least got the closest not to slight his
he seems like a guy who would just be a
director for hire yeah yeah and I don't
necessarily like his movies that I all
of his movies that I've seen have like a
genre Edge mixed with like a sense of
you know fun or humor of some kind I
haven't seen Blair Witch but you know I
can also see how it makes sense but I am
also sort of baffled and surprised you
in mostly Pleasant way that I'm like
really you're you're the guy who nailed
the big Effects movie like good for you
yeah but anyway 31 saying hi guys this
is Trinity hey have you guys seen Rebel
Moon part one it is interesting you give
a Super Chat without realizing that a
whole movie reaction is up here on the
Shen now of us covering Rebel Moon part
one a child of Ice and Fire uh my
anticipated children 2024 movies are
Mean Girls Beetlejuice 2 and
Ghostbusters sequel when I saw the
Taylor Swift concert movie a trailer
started playing and I had I had never
heard of it uh it was the Mean Girls
Musical and I turned to my wife and I
said this is a great idea hey a minger
musical that's that is something that
like if you just told me I'm like yeah I
could see it and uh I love the trailer I
I don't know Renee rap in it okay yeah
yeah she she can she got the pipe I feel
like the the mean I haven't seen the
trailer yet but I feel like the Mean
Girls and and generally the respon you
know they're naysayers but generally the
response is like I'm glad something
agreeable and good maybe came out of
this recent glut of like we got to take
everything and put on Broadway as a
musical like I feel like we're in that
era of uh movie into Broadway so uh I'm
excited to see what the Mean Girls
musical becomes on screen because it's
like yeah this musical on stage was born
out of the movie and now is going to be
returned to movie form a new which is uh
yeah yeah um and the Ghostbuster
sequel who's doing that again the guy
who's for will Keenan who did monster
house and the Poltergeist remake I think
yes which I I recuse myself from
being I have a complex relationship with
Ghostbusters but I I hope it's
fine yeah why do you have such a
complicated relationship with I just
can't get excited for GH but like like
that whole thing in 2016 really did
break me and I'm not trying to grasp
onto it but like now whenever
Ghostbusters crosses my desk it's always
a neutral like okay fine I'll eventually
end up seeing it and I'm sure it'll be
fun but like I I can't get excited for
Ghostbusters anymore and I'm just
waiting I I guess I wasn't really that
um so ugly it was such an ugly
experience and it was very much like a h
yeah this is why we can't have nice
things kind of I don't know people got
really ugly about that movie in a way
that I don't think is appropriate for
any movie I mean it was one of those
like improv movies they slapped together
yeah but it's also like is that why
people upset with it in that say what
you will about the quality of
Ghostbusters 2016 it is more spiritually
in tune with Ghostbusters the original
an irreverent comedy about a bunch of
you know irreverent people working
together on this thing uh whereas you
look at what people seem to want from
Ghostbusters you look at afterlife and
it's steeped in Nostalgia and wonder
which is like fine which you can do I'm
not even opposed to changing the the
tone but everyone's like I am the
gatekeeper of Ghostbusters and this will
not stand and I'm like but you want
something totally different out of
everybody loves afterlife for being a
different kind of movie that's like an
amblin Nostalgia Fest rather than being
like in purity of the Ghostbusters brand
a brand that has one agreeably good
movie and uh yeah just it broke me as
evidenced by this
rant yeah I didn't give a [__] that it
was a bunch of women even though I grew
up on the Ghostbusters movie like I love
I love the first two Ghostbusters I grew
up watching those repetitively the first
one yeah I haven't I don't know if I've
ever fully seen the second I love the
second one there's a dancing toast
tillers well hey excited now I mean I
might it might have been on TV but I
don't have any recollection of no it's
like it's not as good but it's great the
first one I would put on a lot and I
remember always being very confused by
what's happening when Dan acro's pants
open so was someone who who loved those
two movies growing up I wasn't at all
vexed by the idea of like the women
doing it I'm like yeah who gives a [__]
let's just watch this movie I was like
oh a lot of people seem
mad I I really didn't care that it was
like four I I I didn't care and I didn't
mind the movie but the movie is like
just from an objective standpoint it is
essentially just a remake of the
original just with a bunch of improv
slapped around it it's got its own
issues it's it's yeah like as a movie
itself it's not like offensively bad
it's just someone should have edited
this and they should have maybe rained
in some of the Improv I I think and it
was also because you have to understand
John I don't remember what my point was
something about that you should be
utterly reverent about your irreverent
comedy no no no it was about no it was
it was because people wanted a
Ghostbusters 3 conversation for such a
long time going to happen like
Ghostbusters afterlife is the closest we
got to a Ghostbusters 3 and now we're
getting all of them back in Ghostbusters
4 so I guess it worked I guess this is
what we needed to get back to where
people wnab be I'm sorry John but I love
Leslie Jones Leslie Jones is funny I
don't get what your problem this Kate
McKinnon also
funny all right well I'm looking forward
to this new one and I'll tell you why
please because it's the director of
monster house I'm rooting for him and I
think that they actually really got a
cool I'm a big fan of when you create
atmosphere of primarily riant on weather
you know and and this is a really
different type of setting for a
Ghostbusters movie and a different type
of antagonist to go up against like
afterlife thirds of that movie I think
the first two-thirds are great but when
it gets in that that last act I wasn't a
big fan and I was not suckered by my
love and rency that I hold high for
those first two Ghostbusters movies I
grew up on those and it did not work for
me in that moment um and and I thought
that to like a quick remake of the first
movie in the last like 20 minutes so I
wasn't a big fan of it and and uh but
this feels like they can really do
something different H me but we should
move on to the next
one different it's getting late John we
got there's so much to do I got so much
to do today I'm sorry I'll close this
this this lag has ruined everything it's
ruined all of 2024 I might set this
stream to private
guys I'll go back and edit it and I'll
just like dub in the parts that are cut
out we are delaying it even more
34 Vibe
rocks and Shogun FX is probably most
anticipated show for me this year huki
Sonata baby dude the girl from Monarch
in it yeah Kate's in Kate love Kate Kate
she's on the poster now I don't want to
be a samurai I just want to find my
dad be your old character and when I do
find I don't want to fight in feudal
Japan and I always look perfectly
constructed my makeup artist is always
right off camera
I hope shogun's cool I don't know much
about the original or by extension the
reboot but uh it looks cool you don't
know anything about Shoguns well I know
I know historically what role they serve
but uh I don't know anything about the
old shoe the the classic program of
Shogun on television dark which I'm sure
does never get confused they they used
to original title for Breaking Bad was
bad really mhm damn it's called bad bad
Mr White bad and Mad Men was called men
yes Sopranos was called sup sup the wire
was just called the the that's a good
one yeah that's a great but no one knew
exactly what it was about you'll always
have to search it yeah no matter what
you're searching or at least Passion of
the CR was called
passion oh lag before we talked about
dark I was I gave a very in-depth
spoiler talk about dark I'm sorry
sorry I should have been using this to
my advantage to be like I addressed it
it must have been like yep yep yep it
was just all yeah anything lost is is in
the lag don't even trip Ben burkowitz
36 36 Steph Yun rumored to be at of
century I'm bummed me too son of a [__]
Century City that's what you call us
here people are really bummed about that
yeah you know they could have I've I've
seen this outrage about him being out of
century and I look if you feel bummed
about it called Jeff Marvel I'm sorry
that you I'm sorry that it has made you
feel that way I really am I'm not um but
we're here to give our personal opinions
and my personal opinion is I don't
really give a
[__] um I don't so bummer but otherwise
I don't really have a feeling about it
yeah when it comes to Marvel and their
casting and and everything like that
like it's all over the place don't they
they're saying like what's his name
Domingo or what's Domingo yeah yeah
might be the new king oh he and I said
recast him right now recast King right
away it now right away right away can't
oh let's find out let me find out what
Coleman dingo's been because I know I've
seen him in stuff but now I can't
remember what the stuff was all right
he's going to be in Gladiator too yeah
look out look out for Gladiator
2 let's see oh he's in the color purple
he's in Rustin he was on fear of The
Walking Dead he was in Candyman who play
in Candyman it's one of those guys he's
on
Euphoria uh he was in maren's black
bottom it's not that I'm not young who
is
a I think he has trans there there's
something that I think Steph young does
not get enough credit for which is
actually a good thing he doesn't get
enough credit for is it is transcended
being an Asian actor if that makes sense
and like someone who like has been very
much aware of Asian actors the whole
life being
Asian often times you just play the
Asian character and Steph young I feel
point where he he's just Steven young
the actor that you don't need to see him
be like playing an Asian guy necessarily
I'm sure in beef it might be a little
bit more specific sure
but yeah that's smart that's what I do
Joe and and and so to me I'm like yeah I
would love to see Steph young in the MCU
or whatever but like the the debut film
they supposed to be in was like they're
talking about was being Thunderbolts and
it's already like such a super stack
cast that there's already a green time
that they deserved in the other stuff
they were in so maybe they should just
get fleshed out first before you just
start introducing someone else you know
what I mean um and and I think that like
he's I think he's a true amazing actor
Steph young and I I feel like what he
has been able to do Beyond just being
like Asian actor who plays Asian and
Asian filmmakers who will
have I want name specific people right
now but there are people I know of who
like are upand comers and On The Rise
who are like they're usually the scripts
that land their way are like oh it's an
Asian lead it's an Asian person this
because they're Asian and and it's like
they can't they've told me like I can
new people were not just times with
Asian actors that they're usually times
with Asian actors that they're usually
cornered into that where they have to
where they they feel like they have to
constantly be like play some I remember
Sandra o was one of the best cases of
that when she did uh sideways was like
they'd made no I don't recall them doing
any drawing any attention to the fact
that she's Asian in that movie and I
thought that was so to be in this movie
and they have nothing to do with her
being Asian that's what I wish and
that's really where we got to get to you
know I wish that both scripts and
casting breakdowns I get it you're
writing a script and you want to have
like a specific idea of who the person
is but I feel like unless it's important
I feel like scripts and breakdowns
shouldn't have a race on them because
then you can just cast who the best
actor is theoretically unless again it's
a story where you need some kind of
consistency of racial backgrounds or
whatever it is I feel like you know you
always see the break it's like you know
30s white this you know and it's like
why just have it be
30s male or whatever 30s female you know
make it a little more vague so that yeah
I don't know because I feel like too
then that creates a pipeline of like oh
here are the roles that we need to cast
we need to do a call for Asian actor you
know like it it it SE unless it's again
important I mean yeah usually when I see
an Asian person in a in a lead in of
some sort there's usually something
about that their character being Asian
you know which is f like I'm just always
happy to see like there's like it was
cool to see Monarch like it's awesome to
finally see like something in the
Godzilla world where the lead characters
are Asian you know sure but there's
there is the thing where they're
specifically that and that's not a bad
thing it's not bad just it would be nice
to get p and I think usually it's not
Asian exclusive too I think it's often
with anybody's not Caucasian is usually
the case you know if it's a modern day
story you know what I mean yeah yeah and
it's time but like there are other ways
to do it than just being like Oh we did
some Asian cultural things in a scene to
drive home the character development of
this Asian character yeah yeah like
there's I think it's good to do that on
a sometime it depends of the project but
yeah it shouldn't just be that is
basically the
point racial and social it's not a black
and white conversation sometimes it is
like yeah they need to be specifically
that sometimes it needs to be and if it
doesn't need to be and you've made the
choice just commit you know like yeah
commit every character has a different
necess necessity of backstory and by
extension cultural backstory and there
are a lot of great broad reasons to do
that in particular that I think are
lovely and that obviously we need more
of because at the same time I think you
know you also need the opposite side of
the coin where it's like we're not
really focused on that at all and this
character is just a character who
anybody could put themselves into the
shoes of you know
alrighty let's move on let's do it guys
we got to end the super chats John you
said you were going to do that a while
ago all right well ill Tortuga we will
thank you for this moment of silence
while I
dismantle the Monet I'll dismantle
capitalism right now we're going to do
the last of them The Last of Us refresh
let's go through it I got a lot of work
to get through I got to work on a whole
complicated video today get it get the
complex in this context there's no
disrespect
break your
necks uh all righty Darren
memens and uh oh let's see because it's
important to do so unless you tell me to
give up on this and go okay 17 I
remember ke was 17 18 19 20 everybody in
the chat count 21 22 23 24 25 26 27 28
29 30 31 32 2 33 34 35 36 I was off any
and Darren uh or Duren I am excit uh or
Daren I am excited for it I am also
excited for season 3 which I have seen
zero% of and I am excited to watch all
of this on my own
time as I'm sure you are as well as sad
as it is not to to be covering it
specifically no I I
have I I feel bad for them I think they
wanted to go for longer and everything
that's happened at DC has unfortunately
left some disheartening development some
stuff it's that's the part of the gamble
that you take is that there's going to
be some things that have to go that
you're excited that are finally going to
go and then there are other things that
sadly like Superman and Lois probably
just have to go do to it you know just
to keep things more unified and to keep
in line with their universes and all
that [__] release the heckin cut um and
uh it's it's too bad it is too bad um
but I don't know it is what it
is what it is is I'm glad we at least
got four hopefully four is also quality
four quality seasons of a show that
showed what you can do in modern times
with Superman I just hope that those
actors are able to be able to find
something
um Beyond this you know yeah also great
Jimmy witchard shout out great character
pull from one of my favorite shows
Charlie
836 Charlie XCX number 37 Greg's
biceps and John's luscious locks why do
you look so uncomfortable no he's
sweating man they're making him all hot
and bother dude I feel like he's
terrified I'm going to choke him to
death he maybe he's excited you could
choke them to death my biceps aren't
that good guys oh don't shame
yourself I got ways to go call Koy I can
only do like 15 reps 40 lbs hammer curls
a you suck at muscles I need to get to
the worst mus 50
lbs 15 reps okay that's the goal well
really what you want to do is you want
to get to like like the max out part
where you um yeah yeah yeah on like the
eighth or ninth rep especially if you're
trying to go your biceps but I don't
deal with that [__] I just want to get
you
know good fit muscle I don't need to be
huge I just want to have a good
proportionality of
muscles anyway um and yes I will stop
all things so that you guys can behave
ouch man are you doubting my muscle buff
John
2024 get ready I love buff John I can't
imagine what that would be like or so
funny I'm gonna get buffed then I would
love Ro it out just buffed J the day
yeah just stressing out about how he
didn't get his workout sorry man can we
stop this movie for a hot second I need
some more creatine man I need some more
creatine forgot my shake bro I would
love to see that buff John 2024 it's
going to happen and and and and I'm
setting this goal because then I hope
that at least you know you shoot for the
moon you land amongst the Stars maybe
I'll just get fit John instead oh my God
I love it cuz everyone's traded gig Chad
John that's my that's my calling this
year it's what do mean number once
traded well you and KY got all Koy was
like just regular and then he got buff
and then you've been on like this crazy
ass glow up over time where you've just
gotten more buff and handsome and like
your Beard's perfect and the curls and
all that [__] just every time I see you
in Olivia I'm just like these people
just get fitter and fitter that a
necessity to be able to perform at a
high functioning level to be able to
work for it's like okay if I'm going to
work 12
hours this like this is we're just
hanging out right now this is like easy
hly like I can't [__] you guys like
this live stream is fun um you know it's
the other stuff is on the average the
average schedule is like film for two
hours at most usually two to three yeah
that's a that's a whole other thing that
that stuff is not not not as it's fun I
don't I don't really generate fun from
those things but this is like this is
the probably the easi I I like d we're
just talking like this is fun I than the
goddamn lag that [__] ruins yeah
entire experience bummed about that but
hey this is fun 37 thank you Charlie
this is just fun I was this is lag but
yeah Charlie you you inspired me with
your profile pick so thank you for that
30 video when we're doing reactions I'm
like really aware of the edit I'm really
really aware it's hard for me to like
it's hard for me to let go of that I
could be like crying and and being aware
of an edit at the same time sure you
have a great uh balance of awareness
truly do that's what it is so I I I'm
I'll I'll keep uh aspiring Ben buret 37
38 also hello and happy New Year thank
you my friend yeah thank you Ben and 39
IL toruga saying I think you guys should
watch the movie bottoms oh I would love
to see bottoms I'm so excited that
sounds controversial I would L to see no
hard feelings is that worth watching
guys put in the chat is that worth
watching also Ken it's good we can trade
you can get a buzz cut and I'll keep it
long I want to see bottoms and I would
be interested I I think uh you know J
Jay law has the comedy she could do the
comedy chops you know what I
mean but uh bottoms looks like uh a film
that I would actually like
appreciate across the
board that's just me all I believe you
Chuck van are we at 40 40 40 in Super
Chat of the D the best age hey Greg and
Jong longtime listener first time caller
your guys work is much appreciated off
and Rings his pile how about the
Umbrella Academy Season 4 looking
forward to seeing where it goes happy
New Year Umbrella Academy Season
4 I hear it might be their last season
so yeah I'm really I I didn't know this
till after we were done doing the
reactions Aaron and I went down and
because a lot of people felt the same
way we did some people think it's their
best season I I personally thought it
was their weakest of the three and
apparently there it did deal with like
the covid problems surrounding it uh
that they had to work around a lot which
affected it but there was an amazing
Cliffhanger to it I do think to a point
you were making earlier John that you
know it happens with movies and movies
are two out to three hour experience
where you're like what happened in the
last movie again it's been too much of a
wait time a season of Television whilst
taking longer to produce and make and
write it's a lot to more to remember and
so it's a bigger it's a taller order of
your audience ask of them and even here
as like someone who worked on every
video for Umbrella Academy seon reaction
to it literally worked on every video I
still like what happened in that season
again I like I don't remember the end so
what happened and so I need to rewatch
it but I hope that it's able to do
stronger than I remember it had a a
really bomb Cliffhanger I remember the
Cliffhanger being really [__] cool I
remember the feeling I had towards the
Cliffhanger I don't remember the
specifics well enough but it's Umbrella
Academy a lot of like negativity towards
Umbrella Academy Season 3 um and happy
New Year to you but but I feel like
they'd acknowledge uh the incidences
that have happened with it I didn't care
about it being Elliot paage I'll get
that out of the way like it's
not I don't give a [__] about like like
their [__] life you're not outraged
that this person's real life didn't
adhere directly to your fictional piece
of entertainment umbrella season 4 is
going to be the best one Umbrella
Corporation
yep does anybody keep the name straight
I remember one of your videos I think uh
you
know yeah I called Juno at one point and
that got really weird uh Heather gear
happy New Year lovely gents hey Heather
good to see you again the laptop says
hello Heather I just look for it's the
kind of entertainment you get here
you're talking like three coming soon
you thinken movie is coming so many
comments about the [__] it's like
like John where's your reaction this
what the hell is this it's uh in the
works I gave it to the editors and it's
ready God damn about time what took you
so long I Wasing for months oh I wanted
to make it
special what does that mean I don't know
did some special stuff for it all right
well 30 people going to eat it up man
John psych 3 coming soon I can't wait
for it's been a very emotional journey
and it's been like yeah it's dude it's
going to be amazing I can't wait and
then once this one's up it's it's gone
good until psych four comes out no no no
good but we love you Heather gear and
yes it is around the corner this is Gus
is nigh dude I'm hoping Lily Gladstone
um is uh gets a little bit more work out
there yeah and gets to just I mean you
know obviously more native uh indigenous
stories should be told but also just
gets worked as other kinds of characters
too yeah
Tyler
41 they're not out this year but I'm
looking forward to seeing more Superman
news and first looks at the characters
and also more news for the movie critic
by Quinton
Tarantino which is uh going to be his
Star Trek movie it's all about a guy
who's trying to review movies but he's
like a damn isues to deal with how am I
gonna criticize movies if I have to deal
with all this Intergalactic
diplomacy you get a good
text yeah I just I'm just checking my
good text it's not a bunch of like
scheduling got got fun nice easy to
handle conversational want people to try
scheduled like eight different people
non expectational text it's good I need
to I I do need we do need it end yeah um
yeah I'm like way behind more Superman
news will be coming uh you know I think
that'll be the fun part of DC 2024 it's
just getting glimpses oh that's right
it's Tarantino's last year last movie
yeah I'm going to be sad about that that
I'm sad about sure we'll see how long it
lasts but I feel like if anybody could
make lasts him I completely think it's
cage can you imagine if they collabed on
a TV show Nicholas Cage Tarantino has a
show he wrote a whole show I think it's
a Netflix show he's doing he he wrote a
whole show oh damn already yeah he's not
disappearing yeah yeah yeah yeah he's
gonna write books and maybe do TV and
stuff hear that ke might be a good you
know ambus 24 what number is it it's
42 will there be any more Apple TV shows
to watch I recommend checking out the
show
Silo I don't know they got a lot of
stuff coming they're always acquiring
things I mean uh uh that one show that
everybody recommends I want to see at
some point s right now less inclined to
commit to television shows uh just
because when those don't pan out it's a
really shitty commitment in terms of the
feeling of when you put a lot of work
into every video and you know you're
stuck in it for like a whole season and
yeah it's not a good feeling uh to have
so uh due to that the uh I'm less
inclined to just commit to like older
shows right now because there's like
there's a whole a wider when it comes to
okay I'm hiring this person this like
the host here editor help and blah blah
blah blah blah list goes on and on and
on on so that's why it's made like a
movie you can have like a movie reaction
fail but that's like one and done and
it's failed uh but that those actually
have a chance of growing over time and
I've seen it happen like just whereas a
show usually it's stays dead so um we
don't really there there's reasons why I
got to be mindful of it because it's got
to be it's it's a constant like I'm
really proud of 2023 because it's we've
been able to focus on th we really
wanted to do whilst also giving a lot of
our viewers what they would want from us
in order to sustaining enjoyment and and
keeping the channel alive and so when it
comes to TV shows that's like the the
hardest thing to choose from I'm gonna
cover Percy Jackson just because I'm
just like ah [__] it it's
January I'm going to cover it um but and
I I want to cover it it and there's like
a lot of shows I'd love to cover but
yeah Percy Jacks tera's been sick so got
to give her got to give her some hours
to catch up on um so yeah it's a Terra
January it is Terra
January anyway drink your Tannis rout
Angel Batista what number is it John 43
favorite movie reaction of 2023 mine was
How to Train Your Dragon too I really
appreciate that uh I really loved it's a
good call
yeah yeah Demolition Man was pretty damn
fun anything with koi I guess
sure I mean saw 10 was a highlight for
me Fight Club was really fight club was
the solo video that went the way I hoped
it would which was nice I'll take that
uh but I mean there was a lot of good
ones I mean God Barbie was fun Shen
Godzilla was
fun
um five nights for the incredulity alone
was fun um
but yeah I mean Barbie's fine yeah I
like like Dread how to trainer Dragon 2
was a how to trainer Dragon 2 really
surprised me a lot I just covered the
impossible and that surprised me because
I wasn't expecting to get so emotional
and that surprised the hell out of me on
that
one I would love oh nothing but romcoms
in February I would love that honestly I
I loveed like the final destinations
with Roxy those were black
I love doing Little Mermaid with the
misses just because we got to give some
people we we held back talking more than
like or and I when we're alone we talk
Non-Stop and we held
back because you're like we're going to
piss people off if we talk as much as we
do in real life that was that was really
fun to do with her that was really fun
to do with her I very much enjoyed being
introduced to under with Roxy underworld
I became an underworld fan it took me a
minute but especially like reviewing
those to to put them up I was like I
like this even more than when I actually
watched it I really loved the I really
love doing Percy Jackson with ter that
was so fun it's just not a
good they
uh oh God you know oh my God wreck wreck
might have been it it might okay it was
either wreck or I was thinking about
surprised the the hell out of me because
I hadn't ever seen the trailer I didn't
know I knew nothing about it yeah and
that movie just kept getting Wilder and
in ways that I really really appreciated
um it just went there and whenever it
constantly crossed the line into oh my
God is this reck's pretty wreck open my
wreck was the first horror movie I had
seen on the Channel that I couldn't stop
sto thinking about for a while where I
was like I I I found myself like just
from my day-to- day like thinking about
like why that movie works so well um but
from just a pure like a reaction missing
was uh was it was such an such an
experience I want to see that I want to
see missing and I want to see searching
yeah that was uh that was something
rawad Rex I would love to watch just
friends I would love to do that Terra if
you hadn't seen I haven't seen best
friends no dude start writing on every
movie it's time to do every movie this
year why I got an Ever growing list and
I have a lot of romcoms I ain't never
seen so Goddess Isis thank you so much
goddess Greg watch Sucker Punch happy
New Year
all I got I can't lie to you Goddess
Isis what number is she
48 48 okay um there's been so many times
where it's like all right John
I think we're GNA do Sucker Punch this
week all right never mind we can't
something else came up Roxy you haven't
all right we're going to do it you know
I'm just not sure if it'll do well maybe
we won't like it and I don't I don't
know yet all right Aaron see you in I
this week
budy that's the movie everyone has to be
on I just keep putting it off because I
keep worrying that it's going to be
boring I I'm really worried it's gonna I
like to love every Zack Snider movie
even Rebel Moon which has actually gone
down even more so for us like I was not
a big fan of that movie real cut or
whatever they should release a real
movie then but Sucker Punch is one I am
so every time I've seen the trailer I go
damn this looks [__]
sweet but I'm still so hesitant cuz the
last thing I want is to be bored and I
keep getting worried that I'm going to
be bored or off-put or something I'm
just Kidd I don't even know about
off-put I just get worried about being
bored B well and you know that to get
the full experience you will have to
watch the three-hour director's cut
which I could certainly imagine being a
bit of a
great but you
know I don't
know I've I've never
heard that it sustains its cool cool
ability I've heard that was I don't
mind I I don't mind just if I'm not
liking something just saying that I'm
not liking the
movie unless it's sex s but what I don't
like is being bored during a movie and
and so to me I'm just like constantly
concerned that I'm going to be bored but
yeah I hear they're really hot in the
movie Michelle should I be oogling at
them you know yeah it does seem like a a
hashtag problematic movie for multiple
reasons but it is like the better than
the Guardians of Ghul or whatever
Legends of go I'd be interested in see
other other than that it's the only
liveaction Zack Snider movie I have not
seen so I have I do feel like I have to
complete like my filmography of Zack
Snyder might as well do it with a camera
pointed at me yeah well of course it's
Zack Snider you have to also reacting to
Rod Tomato's lowest rated films would be
a blast uh thank you Goddess Isis Brandy
Torres what are we at 48 I'm gonna say
I'm just gonna say 48 you guys need to
react to the Summer I Turned Pretty I
don't know what that is I would like to
have a summer like television show John
oh is it good was Prime video oh who's
on
it I don't know we can watch that and we
can watch
pen5 and we can watch uh
sexed we can watch all these movies
that's a big May because that's the
first time I'm hearing about this show
Brandy I'll check it out at least on my
own and see if I become prettier whilst
watching it guys you hear Mark Hamill
doesn't like me you in particular why
why what' you do to him I asked if I
could have permission I didn't ask
permission to use his deep fake and then
he said knock it off Greg he said no all
I said was no so I made a 12-minute
video about it he hey
history oh go up go up I want to talk
about it I want to talk about D v900 two
shows that I want to come out this year
what number is he 49 good to see you Dan
v900 you're always here um Batman the
cape Crusader I'm looking forward to
Batman the cape crusat but we get so
much Batman I am revitalized something I
imagine it's the kind of thing that we'd
be really excited for at a good amount
of you would be excited for but it ends
up not getting any
viewers Terminator Terminator anime uh
from co-writer of the Batman and so to
me that like I'm a huge fan of the
Terminator franchise Terminator 2 um
easily I fluctuate between that being
one or two is the first like dark fate
John please I'm trying to get through
this
please you love ter
please
Terminator one and Terminator
2 anyway we all know the franchise has
gone down the [__] lately no but I
think an anime I I don't I don't know
what the anime would be I don't know if
they're going to do like a remake of it
or if they're going to set it during the
war and really capture a mood as well as
well because the thing that has severely
been missing is the Menace that James
Cameron brought to those first two films
and that that that mood and tone is so
integral to the Terminator franchise and
they keep wondering like what's I'm like
you know just bringing that back would
do wonders for your films honestly
instead of just making like action films
it a deeper Nuance to it and I think
anime visuals combined with that mood
could do something really cool and you
could probably get some like additional
cooler Terminator [__] to go down you
get really violent as well oh you can do
so much twisted stuff I think yeah oh
and there's like body horror stuff in
those first two Terminator movies liquid
Terminator there you can do some really
great visuals I think uh and and so to
me yeah I feel like uh the Terminator
anime is one I'm except I'm especially
looking forward to yeah well and Cape
Crusader is like Bruce Tim and Company
right so I mean that'll be classic we're
going to be spoiled with some good
animated stuff this year I hope hope the
animation itself is all good Sean F I
think you're number fif hey guys hey
guys thank you for being here I have
been a fan for years thanks for all the
content keep it up thank you Sean F
that's really sweet of you to say Sean
fantastic is what I imagine the F stands
for Dan V is back thank you for being
number 51 as well as 49 I hope alien
Romulus is good where I'm cautiously
Optimist one constantly recommends to me
and hopefully s which are awesome I
forgot Noah Holly is doing an alien
thing I thought alien Romulus and and
the show no I thought they were the same
thing no fetty it's the fetty Alvarez
movie oh that's right that's right
that's right because when they were like
un this the alien Untitled alien thing's
finally going to get a title I'm like
didn't they already title it and then
yeah I keep having to remember that Noah
Holly's doing his thing I'm excited to
see what he comes up with in 2025 I I I
feel like someone who is uh uh Adept at
mindbending would be a nice thing to
throw at alien because I feel like post
aliens the only thing we've really found
works is action intensity which uh I
feel like alien and Terminator uh are to
varying degrees of success we'll see but
uh uh I'm more excited for I mean it's
weird I'm more excited for the filmmaker
behind the show but I'm more excited for
the movie because I feel like um alien
is best when it's simple lean and mean
baby um like alien one and and aliens
are nuanced in it Noah Holly probably
gets really headyy about it and sure I
don't know if like alen is the franchise
to do that with you
know for your ass
aliens that like have no personality so
I don't think they're the ones to do it
for yeah um whereas like alien alien I
think like the best part of of Covenant
was when it got like aggressive
intention scenes and [__] yeah and
that's not that's not even a good movie
you know uh so and that was freaking
Ridley came back right yeah yeah yeah I
mean I I have hope for ramulus because
yeah fedy Alvarez is is good at doing
lean and mean and and straightforward
you know yeah uh as much as again rip to
the Neo Blom Camp version 52 danv just
filling it up we love to see it thank
you for the support and love my top four
movies I'm most excited for Deadpool 3
and NOS forat 2 by Edgars some good
anticipations you got there Tara got
sick a couple weeks ago uh the day she
was coming in to film it she got really
sick so haven't been able to do that
that's why I haven't even done Percy
Jackson uh de and Nas feratu of course
can the plan of the Apes I didn't
realize there were writers returning
from Dawn of the Planet of the Apes for
this which gets me more interested in it
granted so much of it is Matt Reeves's
voice I think his like they this one of
those Studio films where they really
especially if you watch Rise of the
Planet of the Apes and Dawn of the plan
of the Apes you could tell that they
really let their directors have a voice
with these movies and I don't know the
voice of this director granted I didn't
really know Matt Reeves outside of you
know
Cloverfield and the remake of Let Me In
but the remake of Let the Right One In
was essentially just a shot for shot
remake that unlike psycho people were
like it's great even though it's a shoer
shot remake just in English sure yeah
but outside of that I didn't really know
his voice
and I don't feel like the teaser trailer
needed to come out it's a fine teaser
trailer but it didn't demonstrate
anything that really makes it feel
unique or special or return to what
makes those first couple those last like
people really love rise of uh Rise of
the Planet of the Apes but you know it's
like Dawn and and War for the Planet of
the Apes talk more to it I'm a plan I've
seen I think I've seen every Planet of
the Apes movie I I think I
have so yeah I'll be there um but I
think they're theatrical trailer needs
to do something special like the teaser
trailer for Dawn of the Planet of the
Apes was simple I'll still don't forget
it it's just the shot of like Caesar and
the closeup and the Thunder and the rain
the camera slowly pulls back and the
apes are in their trees puts his hand up
simple and that was stri more effective
than anything we got in this Kingdom of
the planet of a St true uh so yeah I
mean I'm looking forward to it but it's
because I'm a planet the a fan it's not
really because of what the trailer
showed me you
know that's a very astute observation I
would agree I know the lag seems to be
less now and that's good because uh I'm
I'm running so bab we're going all right
434 whatever it is TM nerdy Happy New
Year to the best reaction Channel thank
you that's we like to hear thank you so
much Dany back in at 54 I'll say fourth
is furiosa and fifth is Nas farad too
it's got got to update a lot of that is
I don't know man the movie looks [__]
awesome I again Twitter makes me
convinced that everything sucks like
makes me think that everyone thinks
everything sucks because I go on Twitter
and like CGI and all this stuff like
what the [__] do you guys expect to like
Twitter is like nitpick Central yeah uh
I love the trailer for furosa and I I
feel like you know there was so much
backlash at the thought of initially of
you're not going to get Charlie Theon to
return
she made fosa wouldn't be as memorable
if it wasn't for her performance and
then what we see on Taylor Joy doing in
there I think she looks great Chris
Hemsworth I forgot was in it until and
it took me a second to register was him
I love fun Chris Hemsworth and if feels
like it's delivering all the things I
love about the the the last movie which
I barely remember because I was [__]
baked out of my mind when I watched it
so I barely I would like to rewatch Mad
Max Fury well say that one time really
high and I don't remember
it at all all I remember is one I don't
remember I don't remember anything that
nice do a reaction
baby but I wanted to find someone who
hasn't SE it so that way it's like
totally not a waste of time be yeah
filling in my gaps and also this person
first if I wouldn't get in trouble with
YouTube for just saying I was so high
when I watched this I don't remember I
could do so many more movies because you
could just say that you were
sleepy no that's not that's stupid you
could say that you were uh you had a
concussion when you saw all these movies
John did not watch what if season 2 in
his free time he doesn't watch Marvel
unless there's something with the camera
I have to make him watch Civil War oh
that's right yeah yeah well look out and
hey Bucky Barnes just made a a prime
ribbon some mashed potatoes I'm talking
about brought some for everyone uh but
enjoy that also just shouts out to y'all
it's been a very Like Loving positive
chat every time I catch y'all are like
cross talking and being like Oh hey
thanks oh I love you so like it's nice
to see 55 David Cobra Kai season 6
completely forgotten I'm excited for
that Bob Marley One Love Creature
Commandos and the Waller TV show is
cobai season 6 actually coming out this
year I don't know I hadn't seen like an
official announce but it's possible I
feel like they shoot edit and release
them so fast like once they shoot them
they're like it's DB being edited yeah
we shoot these literally in shot
order and whatever we get is what we got
just slap it in the editor and Export it
seems like they released that [__] so
quick once it's shot yeah um so yeah I
I'm look me Cobra Kai man I I I it's
going to be their last seasons and I
imagine it's going to be a banger yeah
oh my God they got to bring in Hillary
swing if they don't bring in Hillary SG
they're doing a crime nine hours ago
Cobra Kai season 6 training video yeah
yeah yeah I heard about that so they
must at least be gearing oh wait confirm
what we got here 10 episodes expanded
run time good and
uh sometime I can't wait yes I think I'm
going to rewatch all Cobra Kai I gotta
rewatch all of Game of Thrones I gotta
rewatch all Cobra Kai got a lot of
rewatching to do all right they're
saying filming is expected to start in
early 2024 which goes in line with your
theory because they want to get it out
in 2024 yeah is what the creators have
said so you know and and hey I mean Bob
Marley be interested to see a fil oh
Kingsley benad deer not bad okay
Creature Commandos and Waller are going
to be interesting to see what Jimmy G's
uh you know DCs are like I I'm also
curious to see what that'll do to the
perception and anticipation of the new
DCU because those will be our first
impressions technically I'm not that
everyone who would see Superman Legacy
will see them yeah but you know curious
not just the same oh my oh my God was he
the last one of the day let's make
doubly absolutely 100% sure but it might
be it might be we might be out of he or
G nope nope but it's close we got a
stick
55 say oh look at that look at that
stick Patrick Robbie our last one of the
day our first super sticker of the day
first super sticker sticker of 2024 yeah
we got a silenced in cast let's just
refresh the streamlabs just to make sure
that no one we do not have letter box no
nope we good we so money baby so money
we I I have a letter boxed account I
just haven't updated it in a long time
did not see the new Echo TV spot we we
don't really cover trailers as much as
we used to obviously if you pay
attention and we don't really Cover TV
spots as much as we used to either yeah
uh guys I do have like a lot of other
things like the the lag thing created a
big lag in the schedule so uh there's a
lot of other things I got to work on
today so I don't turn to a super late
night um but thank you guys so much for
being here with us I really do apologize
for the first stream be as much as I
like to joke about I know I can just
laugh about it later uh it really does
pain me that our first live stream of
the Year turned into a freaking Fiasco
turned into aex support session came
into uh what happened with this lag that
kept happening and of course the last
like 20 minutes of the stream decides
not to do it anymore uh I I really do
apologize I don't know how to
gauge uh next time of how to prevent
that from happening I don't know how to
because YouTube says excellent
connection and [__] so I don't I don't
know how and our internet connection
giving us a warning I mean you know yeah
so I have no idea of how to gauge it but
we'll try the next one in the main
office yeah just to see and then if it
works then we know John was wrong so
we'll just go there and uh thank you
guys so much again uh for mation thank
you to everyone who contribut to our
super chats happy 2024 and if you didn't
that's okay and thank you so much to
everyone who uh no I'm just [__]
around John's great and um and he's
gonna whip me after this thank you guys
uh for um just kicking it with us and
all right we're going to get back to a a
regular regular workflow starting the
next couple minutes much love to all of
you let's have a kickass 2024 yeah kick
starting off with rushing immediately
into the next task got to get going love
you guys thank you guys yeah let's see
all right be well till next time
peace